conséquence que la charge virale c'est
aussi un des reflets de la contagiosité
est ce variant delta nous force nous
pousse à nous retrouver ce soir pourquoi
parce que la reprise épidémique
porté par ce variant delta est une
réalité nous sommes dans une quatrième
vague plus de vingt mille cas
diagnostiqués par jour ces derniers
jours sur le territoire national des
taux d'incidence tel qu'on n'en a jamais
connue depuis le début de la pandémie
dans certains départements comme les
pyrénées-orientales
une épidémie qui touche les jeunes qui
présente plusieurs caractéristiques
d'abord les jeunes ont retrouvé de la
vie c'est tant mieux mais cet heureux
c'était attendu
il fréquente peut-être un peu plus des
milieux festifs ont beaucoup de
relations sociales
et puis les jeunes ne sont pas
suffisamment vacciner l'été dernier nous
avions vu cela mais dans des proportions
bien moindres souvenez-vous avec une
épidémie qui était reparti par la
jeunesse et qui ensuite avait touché les
catégories les plus âgés entraînant une
deuxième bague
l'autre caractéristique c'est que nous
observons une augmentation des
hospitalisations dans notre pays certes
nous partons d'un taux d'hospitalisation
qui bat tant mieux et d'un taux de
réanimation qui est bas à peu près 900
patients en soins critiques et
réanimation dans nos hôpitaux
enfin l'ascension est réel nous sommes à
+ 72 % sur une semaine puis 72%
même si nous partons de bas en termes de
dynamique hospitalière ça n'a rien à
voir avec les vagues nous avions connu
auparavant le sens que nos modélisateurs
les scientifiques du cnrs de l'inserm de
l'institut pasteur qui travaillent dans
ce contexte très particulier d'une
épidémie estivale ce qui est une rareté
dans l'histoire de la virologie
alors que les écoles sont fermées alors
que beaucoup de français se sont
retrouvés en famille et une fois passé
le premier brassage normalement sont
moins sujets à être en contact avec
beaucoup de gens les modélisateurs
travail en partant des données dont il
dispose la contagiosité du variant
l'observation de ce qui se passe à
l'étranger
d'abord en inde ou souvenons nous ça a
été quand même assez terrible qui tienne
compte aussi de notre système testé
alerté protégé qui a montré son
opérationnalité je pense hollande par
exemple avec un effort considérable et
équipe de traçage de l'assurance maladie
de la rs qui ont permis de freiner la
balle épidémie mais ça n'a pas empêché
de partir très fort sur l'ensemble du
territoire
et puis bien sûr ce taux de vaccination
nous sommes
vous dire de bêtises mais nous sommes
pas très loin des 40 millions de primo
injection de sam à 39 millions et demi
ce soit environ 960 860000 injection et
été fait pour moitié des primo injection
de sorte que nous avions fixé un
objectif qui était à 40 millions de
primo vacciner à la fin août et que nous
nous y serons à la fin de la semaine
néanmoins ça laisse encore 12 millions
de personnes vaccinable qui ne le sont
pas et surtout parmi les populations
fragiles les populations qui sont âgées
et ou atteintes de maladies chroniques
qui les expose à des risques de formes
graves comme l'obésité sévère le diabète
des cancers
il reste encore 5 millions de
compatriotes qui n'ont pas été vaccinés
quelles qu'en soient les raisons que ce
soit le refus du vaccin que ce soit la
peur du vaccin ou que c'est pu être les
difficultés pour accéder à la
vaccination des modélisations dont je le
disais nous nous prédisent une vague
forte
j'en avais parlé il ya quelques semaines
de cela je n'avais pas si tort que cela
en parlant d'au moins 15 à 20 mille cas
d'ici à la fin juillet nous y sommes
avec la possibilité d'un impact
hospitalier qui pourrait être très dur
d'ici à la mi ou à la fin août je dis
bien qu'ils pourraient parce que nous
sommes toujours dans du conditionnel
avec les modélisations et qui a des
paramètres que nous ne maîtrisons pas
complètement encore avec ce variant
delta j'observe et peut-être que vous
l'avez observé aussi quand en angleterre
ou en espagne
on constate depuis 24 48 et un
frémissement à la baisse mais avec des
taux de contamination qui restent encore
très élevées et nous avons appris avec
l'expérience que c'est pas parce que ça
fluctue sur deux jours que ça veut dire
c'est fini
parfois une fluctuation précède une
chose qui peut être importante donc nous
devons anticiper
nous devons anticiper la situation face
à laquelle nous pourrions être dans
quelques semaines dans notre pays
il vient au fond jusqu'ici nous avions
deux scénarios le premier c'était le
confinement
nous fermons l'accès à tous les espaces
culturels sportifs économiques pour tous
les français c'est la distanciation
social poussé à son paroxysme
de sorte que les gens ne se contaminent
plus l'épidémie reflux et nous avons
vaincu la vague
la deuxième option certains pays ont
fait ce choix c'est de considérer que
étant donné le taux de couverture
vaccinale
étant donné que la vaccination était
proposé
un grand nombre de français et bien pas
de mesures de gestion ne serait être
prises pas de confinement quelle que
soit la situation et observons s'il ya
un impact sanitaire
et puis il ya une troisième voie c'est
troisième fois les nouvelles nous ne
pouvions pas l'envisager
lors des trois précédentes c'est la voie
dite du pass sanitaires
la philosophie du pass sanitaires dont
je comprends je dis tout de suite
qu'elle puisse heurter dans ses
fondements
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
que je ne stigmatise pas que je ne juge
pas et que je ne critique pas les
français ont le droit de ne pas être en
accord avec les mesures comme le pass
sanitaires je le dis la question elle
est qu'il faut bien choisir parmi ces
trois scénarios que nous disent d'abord
les scientifiques qu'est ce qui fonde la
proposition que nous faisons ce soir les
scientifiques nous disent si nous
fermons l'accès de tous les
établissements recevant du public à tous
les français l'impact sur l'épidémie
serait le même que si nous fermions
l'accès de tous ces établissements aux
seules personnes non vaccinées puisque
les personnes vaccinées ont un risque
résiduel de contamination faible un
risque de formes graves extrêmement
faible et n'entrainerait pas et ne
menace pas les hôpitaux et ne menace pas
les courbes de mortalité de notre pays
elle est là la logique donc je sais que
je vous ai dit il ya quelques mois que
je n'étais pas favorable à l'extension
du pass sanitaires dans les bars les
restaurants
nous étions un certain nombre à le dire
d'ailleurs même parmi vous certains vont
être amenés sans doute à voter cette
mesure ils ne le font pas de gaîté de
coeur mais je n'ai aucun problème à le
dire je n'ai aucun problème à le dire je
vous dis juste que entre trois scénarios
il y en a deux qui me paraissent plus
inacceptable qu'un autre reconfirmer
tout le pays
avec tout ce que ça entraîne sur le plan
social économique psychique pour notre
pays serait une catastrophe
laisser filer l'épidémie on ne se pose
pas trop de questions et en croisant les
doigts ne me semble pas être de nature à
s'intégrer dans la philosophie de notre
pays de notre protection sociale
mais je mets jaune jpac mais je n'ai pas
dit que quelqu'un avait dit ça je vous
pose les scénarios je vous pose des
scénarios sur la table je pense qu'on
fait le même raisonnement que moi je
pense vous fait le même raisonnement
quoi
pas les mêmes choix je pense que le
raisonnement si vous avez une quatrième
voie je serai évidemment enchanté de
l'entendre vous avez donc vous avez donc
pour moi c'est 3 voilà et donc la voix
du passé ni terre elle consiste à dire
toutes les personnes qui sont vaccinées
ne vont pas véritablement voir leur vie
changer et les personnes qui sont ne
sont pas vaccinées doivent absolument se
faire vacciner d'abord pour se protéger
elle-même pour protéger celles et ceux
qui les entourent
pour freiner contre l'épidémie c'est le
sens de la responsabilité collective et
c'est aussi une manière pour eux de ne
pas avoir leur vie qui change avec la
mise en place du pass sanitaires se
passa ni terre nous n'avons pas attendu
la loi pour l'appliquer partout nous
pouvions l'appliquer nous l'avons
étendue pour tous les événements qui
relève est la loi
dès lors qu'il y avait au moins 50
places et donc potentiellement 50
personnes réunies vous le savez par un
décret du 21 juillet est ce ta sanitaire
nous souhaitons désormais l'étendre à
d'autres établissements
comment avons-nous fait la liste de ces
établissements et bien c'est simplement
l'ensemble des activités qui ont amené à
être fermée pendant les confinements
précédent incluant donc je sais que vous
avez eu ce débat en commission mais
mesdames et messieurs le rapporteur
incluant les centres commerciaux les
grands centres de plus d'un mille carré
ont fermé pendant des vagues précédentes
et nous ne souhaitons pas les refermer
mais pour éviter les refermer alors que
ce sont des lieux à risques de
contamination il faut en faire des
sanctuaires protéger des contaminations
donc du coc vide et donc la clé c'est le
pass sanitaire de la même manière pour
les grands transport savait qu'on avait
interdit pendant un moment pendant les
précédents confinement les transports
interrégionaux sur des longues distances
nous souhaitons conserver la capacité de
mobilité sur tout le territoire national
à l'ensemble des français
ce qui implique là aussi d'utiliser
l'outil pas salutaire pour en faire des
sanctuaires
ça c'est la logique du pass se passe
nous souhaitons pouvoir l'appliquer le
plus tôt possible de manière à limiter
les risques d'explosion de la vague
épidémique est donc de limiter les
situations d'urgence qui lui pourrait
nous contraindre à mettre en place du
freinage pouvant aller à des fermetures
administratives
vous avez sans doute vu que dans
certains départements notamment les
pyrénées orientales
il y a déjà des fermetures
d'établissements recevant du public à
partir de 23h et nous ne souhaitons pas
diffuser ces mesures dans les autres
départements qui sont touchés nous
souhaitons rester à la gestion par le
pastel
terre et puis ce pas sanitaires il a
vocation à disparaître le plus tôt
possible et le plus tôt sera le mieux
alors il ya plusieurs scénarios il y a
le scénario dans lequel tout le monde
serait vacciné où tout le monde sera
vacciné évidemment si tout le monde est
vaccinée ça ne fait plus de sens de
vérifier si vous êtes vacciné ou non
pour entrer dans un établissement
donc dès lors que nous avons atteint
l'immunité collective le pass perd son
sens et disparaît l'autre possibilité
c'est que la vague que nous affrontons
disparaisse et que nous soyons un niveau
de contamination tellement faibles que
nous puissions relâcher les contraintes
et laisser les français retrouvé la vie
de tous les jours ce que nous avons
toujours fait dès que nous avons pu le
faire
nous sommes d'ailleurs régulièrement
taxé d'avoir fait pris ses décisions de
relâchement trop tôt puis parfois trop
tard et puis parfois les deux voilà pour
le pass sanitaires en parallèle de cela
nous voulons booster la vaccination le
plus possible et le président la
république a été très clair le premier
ministre également et nous mettons à
disposition d'un maximum de français des
doses de vaccins dans tous les centres
qui sont ouverts et vous constatez que
nous avons beau être à la fin juillet et
je tire mon chapeau aux collectivités et
aux médecins et aux pharmaciens aux
pompiers à tous les agents qui bien que
vous soyez en fin juillet
non seulement maintiennent leurs
capacités de vaccination mais réussit à
l'augmenter puisque cette semaine nous
allons battre le record du nombre de
vaccinations fait dans notre pays c'est
vaccination augmente également dans les
pharmacies d'officine et donc plusieurs
millions de français pourront bénéficier
d'une première injection l'objectif vous
le connaissez eelv et que nous ayons
atteint les 45 à 50 millions de primo
vaccination dans les prochaines semaines
sur une cible au total de 52 millions
c'est à dire que si nous avions si nous
pouvions vacciner ne serait-ce que 48 ou
49 millions pourquoi pas 50 visons haut
sur les 52 nous aurions de fait atteint
une immunité collective parmi la
population vaccinable les plus les plus
petits ceux de moins de 12 ans ne
pouvant pas être vaccinés puisqu'il n'ya
pas d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
les études ne sont pas terminées sur ce
point là donc ça fait vraiment le double
enjeu pas sanitaires et vaccination
d'une part ensuite il y à un public que
nous avons applaudi à 20h pour lequel
nous avons le plus grand respect et nous
leur devons qu'ils continuent de se
battre dans les hôpitaux qui nous
demandent d'ailleurs d'agir pour un
grand nombre d'entre eux et qui pour un
certain nombre ne sont pas suffisamment
vacciner je parle évidemment de
l'ensemble des professionnels
du soin de santé et d'accompagnement
dans les établissements sanitaires
médicaux sociaux et au domicile c'est
une population aux professionnels très
large dont les taux de couverture
vaccinale sont variables chez les
médecins les pharmaciens nous attend
nous atteignons plus de 90% de
vaccination complète chez les infirmiers
nous sommes à plus de soixante dix
bientôt 75% de vacciner chez les aides
soignants nous sommes à un peu plus
entre 60 et 65% ce sont des données que
nous allons réactualisé en quelques
jours qui sont sans doute un peu plus
importante aujourd'hui c'est tant mieux
et puis chez les auxiliaires médicaux
chez le personnel d'entretien des
établissements nous sommes avec toute
couverture qui sont encore un peu plus
faible et là vous vous dites comme moi
il ya des catégories de professionnels
qui sont en contacts au quotidien avec
des personnes fragiles parce que malades
ou très âgés qui sont moins vacciner que
la population générale qui sont moins
vacciner la population générale
or même si on utilise le masque même si
on fait évidemment très attention parce
qu'on veut contaminer personne même si
on se lave les mains très régulièrement
qu'on met du gel hydroalcoolique le
risque de faire entrer le virus dans un
établissement pour personnes âgées ou
dans un hôpital est réel et dans un
hôpital ou dans un ehpad
même si les personnes sont vaccinées
leur immunité est par définition plus
fragiles parce qu'elles sont plus âgé
parce qu'elles ont des cancers parce
qu'elles sont des infections et que la
vaccination même complète chez eux n'a
pas le même impact que chez vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
donc nous devons absolument renforcer la
couverture vaccinale de ses personnels
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas une nouveauté ça
a été fait pour la diphtérie le tétanos
la poliomyélite ça a été fait pour
l'hépatite b et un certain nombre de
soignants dans cet hémicycle je le fais
sont forcément vaccinés contre ces
maladies sinon on n'aurait pas pu porter
la blouse pour être au contact de
personnes malades
les dispositifs existent donc dans le
droit commun et nous souhaitons
l'étendre pour lakovic 19 avec un
objectif qui a été fixée au 15 septembre
date à partir de laquelle personne ne
sera renvoyé mai date à partir de
laquelle des contrôles de la
mobilisation sera effectuée
individuelles et à partir de là si
véritablement il ya un refus de
vaccination de la part des soignants des
procédures disciplinaires peuvent être
engagés comme elle existe dans le droit
commun s'agissant de la vaccination
contre l'hépatite b par exemple
s'adapter mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs plutôt à gauche
je d'edith cresson et comme c'était le
cas pour le dtp mesdames et messieurs la
droite s'adapter d'un gouvernement de
droite dont le nom m'échappe à cette
heure tardive pardonnez moi donc on
n'est pas là dans quelque chose qui est
du domaine du clivage politique puisque
chacun en responsabilités en son temps
année a été amené à prendre cette
décision difficile mais nécessaire
j'ai réuni les cet ordre professionnel
les huit fédérations d'établissements de
santé qui se sont engagés par écrit
considérant que la vaccination quand on
soigne et quand on prend soin des
personnes fragiles était une obligation
morale éthique professionnelle
déontologiques et appelant s'il le
fallait à la vaccination obligatoire
voilà pour ce point de la vaccination
obligatoire
l'autre élément important fondamental de
ce projet de loi est un élément autour
duquel nous avons tourné pendant 18 mois
jean nous avons eu plusieurs fois les
débats dans cet hémicycle vous
connaissez ma position sur cette
question et je connais la vôtre pour les
uns et les autres
je parle évidemment de l' isolement 10
contre 1 là aussi la situation a évolué
première vague deuxième vague peur
importante découverte est faite
sidération les personnes malades restée
globalement chez elle on a vu ensuite
que c'était un petit peu plus difficile
nous avons mis à disposition de ces
personnes des mesures d'accompagnement
humain avec le passage infirmiers qui
est proposée systématiquement avec des
cellules territoriales d'appui à
d'isolement qui peuvent vous accompagner
pour vos courses vous gardez vos enfants
pour toutes les aides du quotidien y
compris les administrative ya même des
impôts qui ont été déclarés par des
cellules territoriales d'appui isolement
chez des personnes âgées qui ne
pouvaient pas recevoir la visite de
leurs familles pour les aider comme elle
le faisait d'habitude
et puis il ya la possibilité
d'hébergement alternatif pour les gens
dans les conditions d'isolement ne sont
pas réunies hélas ce que nous constatons
c'est que l'acceptation de l'isolément
quand on n'est qu'à positifs et
notamment et notamment quand on est peu
symptomatiques et donc notamment quand
on n'est pas très âgé parce qu'on fait
moins de formes symptomatiques
cette capacité de respecter l'isolément
elle a chuté elle a chuté et aujourd'hui
des études qui montrent dans certaines
régions qu'on est à moins de 40% du
respect de l'isolément pour des gens qui
sont positifs donc contagieux et ça
c'est un problème et ça c'est un
problème parce que si vous sortez de
chez vous êtes content
je viens l'épidémie ne doit pas
s'arrêter ça c'est certain
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons une
disposition qui va plus loin que ce que
nous avons fait jusqu'à présent qui
rejoint des mesures ont été prises par
d'autres pays qui est une mesure
d'isolement contre un avec une
automaticité de la contrainte pourquoi
j'ai vu les travaux vous avez eu en
commission vous souhaitez avoir une
évolution en deux temps avec un temps où
on prescrit un isolement
et en cas de problème on prononce en
isolement contre un avec possibilité
d'intervention on peut le faire quand il
ya vingt cinq ans tu as les 500 terre
par jour dans notre pays
d'ailleurs nous le faisons pour les
personnes qui reviennent de l'étranger
nous l'avons utilisé sur arrêté
préfectoral individuel quand on est à 21
milles ou 22000 peut-être demain 30
mille ou quarante mille contaminés par
jour c'est absolument impossible d'une
part l'assurance maladie ne dispose pas
des capacités de contrôle et une
mobilisation d'agents pour aller chez
les personnes saines
je vous le dis tout de suite d'autre
part en terme de pardonnez moi mais de
techno de techno mesure on ferait
difficilement plus compliqué même si je
comprends parfaitement l'esprit ce que
je vous propose en revanche c'est d'en
revenir au texte de l'assemblée qui
prévoit qu'il y ait une automaticité les
allemands contre un et je vais vous en
expliquer la philosophie philosophie
n'est pas qu'il y à un agent de police
qui se présentent chez vous si vous êtes
diagnostiqué positif au coronavirus et
quand vous demande de vizille et la
philosophie elle consiste à ce qu'on
continue de vous appeler comme nous le
faisons assurance-maladie agences
régionales de santé
une fois deux fois on vous envoie un
médecin si besoin une infirmière qui
devenir la cellule territoriale d'appui
pour vous accompagner dans votre
isolement par contre un moment où on se
rend compte qu'on n'arrive pas à vous
joindre
vous n'avez pas répondu au contact
racing on a envoyé quelqu'un tapait à
votre porte
mais on peut pas forcer à ouvrir et vous
et on ne peut pas on ne peut donc pas
garantir que ne serait ce que vous
alliez bien et puis surtout que vous
respectez les conditions d'isolement et
là on peut avoir une saisine des forces
de sécurité intérieure qui elles sont
habilitées à lécher les gens même si les
gens ne sont pas d'accord pour vérifier
déjà si vous allez bien et si vous
n'êtes pas là se poser la question de
savoir comment est ce que vous respectez
votre isolement et là on rejoint un
dispositif qui est finalement quand vous
êtes mis en arrêt maladie avec un
certificat d'arrêt de travail
vous avez comme cette médecin vous
signez des cases des cocher des cases
est notamment sorti libre ou sorties
interdite est sorti libre
les horaires de sortie est vraiment des
contrôles inopinés et si on vous
contrôle et c'est surtout les arrêts de
travail
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
si quand on vous contrôle si vous n'êtes
pas chez vous et bien les indemnités
journalières saute c'est le dispositif
c'est le dispositif qui existe
aujourd'hui dans le droit commun vous
avez le droit de le remettre en question
que dans un futur projet doit peut-être
mais aujourd'hui c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne sur les arrêts maladie et les
les arrêts de travail et ça vient de
dames et messieurs d'un gouvernement où
il s'était l'union de la gauche qui
prévalait au gouvernement et je pense
pas que ce soit une mesure antisociale
voilà donc là les trois les trois
mesures essentielles par ailleurs vous
le savez il y à la question et c'est qui
a fait débat en commission il ya la
question de la durée tout ces mesures et
c'est une question que nous débattons
systématiquement vous le reconnaîtrez
systématiquement nous proposons une date
est systématiquement elle est raboté et
systématiquement on se retrouve avant la
fin de la date pour pouvoir passer un
nouveau texte
moi je vous ferai la même réponse que
celle que je vous fais à chaque fois et
vous pouvez constater que vous ai jamais
menti puisque me voilà encore devant que
ce soir c'est que d'une part à chaque
fois qu'il aura besoin qu'on se voie je
viendrai je viendrai et j'étais madame
la présidente
la commission au sénat il ya deux
semaines je crois à la demande de la
commission et je reviendrai autant de
fois qu'il le faudra
d'autre part et d'autre part s'il n'y a
plus besoin d'utiliser un pas salutaire
parce que nous en sommes sortis avant le
31 décembre il n'y a aucune raison que
nous le conservions puisque je vous
rappelle encore une fois qu'à chaque
fois que nous avons pris des mesures de
contrainte
nous avons supprimé dès que nous avons
pu et en général on nous a reproché
d'avoir fait trop tôt je le redis et
donc je tout ce que je vous demande
c'est de ne pas nous mettre dans une
situation qui serait que nous serions
obligés de préparer un nouveau projet de
loi dans un mois en vue de vous le
présenter début septembre par
anticipation la situation en octobre
mais on aimerait on aime bien recevoir
monsieur le sénateur et moi aussi j'aime
bien vouloir garder je suis je suis
d'humeur enjouée d'être d'être devant
vous ce soir même si nous allons nous
répartir les rôles avec brigitte
bourguignon qui m'a ministre délégué
pour plusieurs raisons d'une part parce
que une semaine parlementaire très
chargé jour et nuit et je sais je sais
et d'autre part il y a à la fois la
campagne vaccinale justement à booster
et d'autre part la cession de crise
sanitaire qui doit quand même donc
occuper un petit peu notamment avec la
situation ne s'est pas parlé mais
situations ultra marines je ne sais pas
si les sénateurs d'outre-mer
sont présents dans l'hémicycle mais vous
aurez vu madame la série vous aurez vu
que nous avons promis nous avons
déclenché l'état d'urgence sanitaire en
guadeloupe compte tenu de la situation
épidémique et que nous restons
extrêmement extrêmement en alarme quant
à la situation en martinique avec des
taux d'incidence qui sont très élevés un
taux de vaccination qui est extrêmement
faible et une situation hospitalière qui
est très tendue notamment dans cette
période estivale notamment ses pairs
nicipal tous à nous mobiliser nos
mobilisera évidemment tout l'été voilà
mesdames et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les grandes lignes à la fois
de l'état d'esprit qui est le nôtre de
la raison pour laquelle nous vous
présentons ce projet de loi le la façon
d'appréhender plus ou moins positivement
mais toujours de manière constructive
les transformations assez profondes qui
ont été apportées en commission
sénatoriale dans la tente de pouvoir en
débattre avec vous j'ai oublié un
dernier point même si j'en ai déjà parlé
si vous avez supprimé le recours aux
passes sanitaires dans les centre
commercial dans les centres ou dans nos
cordes centres commerciaux les grands
centres commerciaux on parle là de
centres commerciaux qui font plus de
vingt mille mètres carrés il y en a pas
beaucoup
avec une attention évidemment porter aux
autres de chalandise en ne bloquant pas
l'accès aux biens essentiels dans les
territoires mais je vous le redis non
pas comme une menace mais je vous le
redis certaine je ne permettrai pas mais
je vous le redis
parce que avec la capacité d'anticiper
qui est désormais la nôtre
collectivement si ça flambe et qu'on
peut pas utiliser pas sanitaires dans
les passes attendez vous à ce que nous
soyons obligés de les fermer et ses
grands centres et nous ne souhaitons pas
les fermer
nous ne souhaitons pas les fermer et moi
nous avons doughty a utilisé au cas où
plus dans l'urgence nous seront
dépourvues d'autre solution que celle
qui consiste à laisser filer l'épidémie
ou à fermer et je vous le redis nous ne
laisserons jamais filet l'épidémie merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le ministre la
parole à monsieur philippe bas
rapporteur de la commission des lois
pour dix minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
parfois
madame le président madame et monsieur
les ministres madame et monsieur les
présidents de nos commissions
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues
la flambée actuelle de l'épidémie
justifie des mesures d'urgence et
d'exception pour lui donner un coup
d'arrêt avec déjà plus de 20000
contamination journalières la vague et
de grande ampleur
la situation ressemble à celle qui ont
conduit aux trois confinement que la
france a subi
qui oserait faire le pari que la
situation sanitaire sous prétexte que le
nombre d'essais des essais ne s'est pas
envolée va rester stable malgré la
dégradation très rapide des indicateurs
de contamination
faut-il réellement attendre la preuve
par neuf
c'est à dire une forte augmentation du
nombre des victimes pour agir c'est un
risque que je ne vous proposerai pas de
prendre
faut-il alors confié la france confiné
la france une quatrième fois
chacun d'entre vous voudrez éviter le
gouvernement nous propose de tenter de
le faire par la combinaison de trois
moyens l'obligation du pass sanitaires
pour l'accès à certains lieux la mise à
l'isolément forcé pour nos concitoyens
contaminés la vaccination des
professionnels au contact de personnes
vulnérables
nul ne peut dire que cela sera suffisant
mais je vais vous recommander de donner
ses chances à ce dispositif en vous
proposant toutefois de le rendre plus
simple plus claire plus efficace plus
respectueux des libertés
je vais donc vous proposer de prendre
position sur ces questions essentielles
la première est celle du cadre de
l'action des pouvoirs publics
sommes nous toujours dans la gestion de
la sortie de l'urgence sanitaire ou
sommes-nous revenus dans l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
il est clair qu un régime de pouvoir
exceptionnelle justifiée par une flambée
des contaminations par un variant de
vous ne cessez de rappeler monsieur le
ministre que sa charge virale est mille
fois plus élevé que le virus initial ne
peut se justifier à l'évidence que par
le retour à l'état d'urgence
la privation de droits fondamentaux pour
toutes les personnes qui ne peuvent
produire un pass sanitaire l'obligation
vaccinale imposé à des catégories très
large de professionnels la mise à
l'isolément des porteurs du virus
constituent des mesures tellement
exorbitante du droit commun qu'elles ne
sont concevables qu à titre temporaire
dans le cadre d'une urgence sanitaire
reconnu et sous un contrôle
parlementaire et juridictionnelles
accrue la seconde question est celle de
la durée de l'habilitation donnée par le
parlement pour l'application de ces
mesures
nous ne pouvons permettre monsieur le
ministre au gouvernement de maintenir de
sa propre initiative et à sa discrétion
pendant une durée de plus de cinq mois
un régime d'exception frappant aussi
massivement les français dans leur droit
essentiel cela créerait un précédent
dangereux pour les traitement des crises
de toute nature auxquels notre nation ne
manquera pas d'être confrontée à
l'avenir l'histoire ne s'arrêtera pas
avec la fin de la crise sanitaire nous
avons une responsabilité pour la
pérennité de l'état de droit comme plus
immédiates pour la protection de la
santé des français
je vais donc vous demander mes chers
collègues de ne consentir les pouvoirs
exceptionnels demandé par le
gouvernement que jusqu'au 31 octobre
prochain et non jusqu'au 31 décembre au
31 octobre
deux choses l'une soit le pari risqué
d'une maîtrise de l'épidémie aura été
heureusement gagner et ne sera pas utile
de maintenir à ce degré la suspension
des libertés jusqu'au 31 décembre soit
au contraire l'épidémie n'aura pas été
jugulée et des mesures supplémentaires
devront être prises ou l'ont d'ailleurs
déjà été et ce sera si grave alors que
cela ne pourra être fait sans une
nouvelle autorisation du parlement
dans les deux cas c'est au parlement de
décider sans déléguer son pouvoir
le le corollaire de tout ceci et c'est
la troisième question que je vais vous
demander de trancher c'est que compte
tenu de la gravité de la situation
si le gouvernement décidait et ne
souhaite pas nous non plus de rétablir
le couvre feu ou le confinement sur tout
ou partie du territoire national et il
le peut déjà il faut que ce décret qu'il
prendra ne puisse appliquer au delà d'un
mois sans autorisation du parlement pour
exercer notre contrôle nous devons aussi
demandé au gouvernement d'évaluer et de
rendre public chaque semaine les
résultats de l'action que nous
l'autoriseront à mettre en oeuvre
nous pourrons alors s'il ya lieu
délibéré de manière éclairée
s'il faut une nouvelle loi quatrième
question comment contrôler et
sanctionner l'anglais l'obligation de
présentation du pass sanitaires le
gouvernement nous propose un dispositif
reposant sur des sanctions pénales
celle ci était à l'origine tout à fait
disproportionnée le conseil d'état qui a
mis bon ordre mais c'est le dispositif
lui-même qui me paraît devoir être revu
pour plus d'efficacité
au lieu de prévoir un régime pénal qui
risque de ne pas être efficace en raison
de sa lenteur et des incertitudes sur le
prononcé des sanctions
je vous propose un régime de police
administrative très simple mise en
demeure de se conformer aux obligations
prévues par la loi sous 24 heures
à défaut
suspension de l'activité de
l'établissement pendant sept jours puis
en cas de récidive les sanctions pénales
pourront s'y ajouter mais seulement
après le système sera rapide dissuasif
et donc efficace cinquième question
comment assurer l'effectivité de l'
isolement des personnes contaminées au
lieu d'hébergement de leur choix là
encore le gouvernement me paraît se
montrer inutilement répressif comme si
la peur du gendarme et du juge était
susceptible de régler tous les problèmes
il veut aussi que la police et la
gendarmerie est accès via les
préfectures officier de santé publique
dont nous avons autorisé l'an dernier la
création pour l'identification et la
protection des personnes qui ont été
exposées à une contamination
et cela afin de contrôler l'isolément
des personnes contaminées et de faire
sanctionner sa violation
mais ce serait un précédent dangereux de
donner accès à des données de santé aux
autorités en charge de la sécurité
publique la présidente de la cnil n'a
pas manqué de le souligner et c'est une
vue de l'esprit que de penser que la
police et la gendarmerie vont pouvoir
effectivement assumées des contrôles
massifs du placement à l'isolément
s'ajoutant au contrôle du respect du
pass sanitaire est alors messieurs
ordinaires déjà si lourde
j'ai donc vous proposer une autre
répartition des tâches mais vous l'avez
vous même esquissé monsieur le ministre
les agents de l'assurance maladie qui
gère les plateformes chargé du traçage
et ceux qui gèrent le contrôle des
arrêts de travail pour maladie
procéderont à des contrôles
téléphoniques et sur place s'ils
constatent ou soupçonne que l' isolement
n'est pas respectée ils saisiront l'
agence régionale de santé pour qu'un
arrêté préfectoral de placement à
l'isolément soit immédiatement pris cet
arrêté sera notifiée à la police ou à la
gendarmerie du lieu d'hébergement
alors et alors seulement c'est à dire
par exception une procédure répressive
pourra effectivement être mise en oeuvre
sans que jamais des préfectures est
accès au fichier des personnes
contaminées sixième question
faut-il rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous les adultes
cette hypothèse est parfois présentée
comme une alternative aux dispositifs
proposés
ce n'est pas le cas de mon point de vue
l'obligation vaccinale ne peut donner un
coup d'arrêt ici et maintenant à la
flambée de l'épidémie obligations ou pas
obligation il faut plusieurs mois pour
pouvoir immuniser les millions de
français qui ne le sont pas encore
pendant ce temps l'épidémie exploserait
qui plus est il ne suffit pas de
déclarer obligatoire la vaccination pour
qu'elle soit effective ce n'est pas la
même chose
le ministre a justement mis en évidence
l'impossibilité matérielle de la
contrainte si elle doit s'exercer sur
des millions d'individus en même temps
l'obligation risquerait donc de n'être
que proclament à thouars rien
n'interdirait cependant d'approfondir ce
débat dans les mois qui viennent si des
solutions ont été trouvées pour
surmonter ces obstacles
mais pour le moment l'essentiel est de
réenclencher une dynamique de
vaccination massive
et il semble bien que cela commence à
être le cas ce qui est important
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
madame la ministre
au total c'est de respecter les français
et leur autonomie de décision de ne pas
les infantiliser ni les traités a priori
comme des délinquants en puissance
l'état est d'abord là pour entraîner et
pour convaincre pas pour punir
sanctionné et contraindre la réussite
passe par le retour de la confiance
profondément altérée par les vagues
récidivantes de la crise sanitaire et je
dois le dire aussi par les tâtonnements
de la gestion de crise depuis 16 mois on
aura jamais assez de policiers de
gendarmes et de juges pour contrôler et
sanctionner la masse immense des
situations les mesures sanitaires seront
appliquées à la fin c'est donc bien la
libre volonté des français qui sera
déterminante
mais la parole et à madame chantal de
seine rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales pour cinq minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente madame et monsieur
ministre madame et monsieur les
présidents mes chers collègues
la france fait face depuis le début du
mois de juillet à un risque de nouvelle
vague épidémique d'une ampleur
potentiellement inédite ce risque qu un
incident avec la diffusion rapide du
variant delta sensiblement plus
transmissible que les précédents variant
ainsi qu'avec un ralentissement du
rythme de la vaccination au mois de juin
dans ce contexte je partage les deux
constats posés par le projet de loi
présenté par le gouvernement d'une part
une réaction urgente s'impose pour
traîner cette reprise
d'autre part la vaccination est notre
meilleure arme pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
ne nous leurrons pas l'extension du pass
sanitaire constitue une incitation
particulièrement puissante à la
vaccination en population générale
certains y verront même une vaccination
obligatoire qui ne dit pas son nom
peu importe le nom qu'on lui donne la
commission soutient sans complexe cette
fratrie qui lui apparaît pleinement
justifiée au regard de la reprise
épidémique brutale alimentée par le
variant delta
rappelons que selon les chiffres du
ministère de la santé les non vaccinés
ont représenté 80% des cas positifs à la
fin du mois de juin et au début de
juillet au delà de l'obligation
vaccinale des professionnels en contact
avec des personnes vulnérables
il appartient donc à l'ensemble des
pouvoirs publics de faire oeuvre de
pédagogie et d'exemplarité pour emporter
l'adhésion massive de la population aux
solide' qui nous permettra de sortir
durablement de cette crise
dans cet exercice que je c'est délicat
vous pouvez compter monsieur le ministre
sur le soutien déterminé de très
nombreux parlementaires qui sont prêts à
porter le message suivant les vaccins
contre la copie de 19 sont très
efficaces et sûrs janvier aux
modifications apportées par la
commission des affaires sociales à ce
texte
l'article 5 prévoit une vaccination
obligatoire pour toute une série de
professionnels ou de personnels au
contact de personnes vulnérables
la commission des affaires sociales
souscrit à l'idée selon laquelle cette
obligation vaccinale contre lacko vide
participe du devoir d'exemplarité
mais aussi du devoir éthique des
soignants de ne pas nuire en protégeant
les personnes vulnérables qui sont
amenés à prendre en charge la commission
s'est interrogé sur le périmètre des
personnes concernées par la vaccination
obligatoire
initialement proposée par le
gouvernement directement liées au
secteur sanitaire et médico-social mais
elle a fait le choix de ne pas le
modifier
en revanche elle a veillé à garantir à
la mobilisation de l'expertisé de la
haute autorité de santé sur la
détermination des justificatifs
attestant de la satisfaction de
l'obligation vaccinale ainsi que sur une
éventuelle décision par laquelle le
gouvernement serait amené à suspendre
l'obligation vaccinale l'article 6
définit les conditions de présentation
de la satisfaction à l'obligation
vaccinale pour les personnes concernées
à cet égard la commission a renforcé la
protection du secret médical et
sécuriser les modalités de transmission
et de conservation des informations
tirées du contrôle des justificatifs
l'article 7 la commission a complété en
premier lieu les souplesses destiné à
permettre aux professionnels soumis à
l'obligation vaccinale de poursuivre
leurs activités en se conformant à cette
exigence dans des délais raisonnables
elle a ainsi prévu une période
complémentaire du 15 septembre au 15
octobre pendant laquelle les
professionnels pourront poursuivre leurs
activités même si leur vaccination n'est
pas complète
dès lors qu'ils vont démontrer leur
engagement à se faire vacciner par là
par l'administration d'une première dose
et sous réserve bien entendu de
présenter le résultat négatif d'un tests
virologiques
il convient en effet de ne pas faire de
la date du 15 septembre un couple et
punitifs et de tenir compte des
difficultés que pourraient rencontrer
les professionnels pour se faire
vacciner dans les délais par ailleurs la
commission a précisé les conséquences
pour l'emploi qui devront être tirées
d'une interdiction d'exercer
pour défaut de vaccination la suspension
des fonctions ou du contrat de travail
assorti d'une interruption du versement
de la rémunération constitue en effet la
sanction la plus équilibrée
elle constitue une incitation puissante
des professionnels les plus réticents à
rejoindre les rangs de leurs collègues
vacciner en revanche un licenciement à
l'issue de deux mois de suspension
apparaît manifestement disproportionnée
c'est pourquoi la commission est revenu
sur la création d'un motif spécifique de
licenciement tiré de la persistance du
refus de se faire vacciner
au delà d'une période d'interdiction
d'exercer de deux mois enfin à l'article
9 qui prévoit une autorisation d'absence
pour un salarié ou un agent public se
rendant à un rendez-vous de vaccination
contre la copie de 19
la commission a étendu cette
autorisation d'absence aux salariés et
agents publics qui doivent accompagner
leurs enfants éligibles à la vaccination
contre la coved
voici mes chers collègues l'esprit des
modifications qui ont été apportées par
la commission des affaires sociales à ce
texte avec le souci constant de garantir
la pleine effectivité du dispositif d'
obligation vaccinale
je vous remercie dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur stéphane ravier pour 3 minutes
chers collègues
alors le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues se passe ou plutôt
sept ans vice sanitaire que vous nous
demandez de voter est le parfait symbole
du quinquennat
un quinquennat qui aura été jalonnée par
les injures et le mépris de l'exécutif
envers le peuple français souvenons nous
gaulois réfractaires feignant mafieux
ceux qui ne sont rien illettrés
alcoolique et encore récemment
capricieux défaitiste et j'en oublie
sûrement
quand le pays réel a dit stop
quand il est descendu sur les
ronds-points vêtus de ce gilet jaune de
détresse l'elysée a répondu par la plus
violente répression qu'un mouvement
social et eu à subir depuis des
décennies le peuple français ne vous en
déplaise monsieur le ministre il est
enraciné attaché à son pays à son
histoire à son identité à sa liberté
incapable de comprendre et français le
gouvernement a été incapable de le
convaincre de sa politique sanitaire
il est vrai qu'il a multiplié les filets
fiasco investissements dans l'hôpital
public sacrifier mensonge échec
lamentable sur les masques rappelez vous
il suffisait d'éternuer dans son coude
pour éviter la contamination refus
dogmatique que de fermer les frontières
incapacité à mettre des tests à
disposition changement d'avis permanent
il s'est donc rabattu sur la seule arme
qui du reste est l'enfermement
généraliser le confinement et pendant
que la racaille ethniques continuent à
faire régner le chaos et la terreur que
les islamistes conquiert chaque jour de
nouveaux territoires
le gouvernement reste impitoyable mais
avec les honnêtes gens
aujourd'hui il veut à nouveau faire
usage de la trique et diffuse plus
encore le virus mortel de la division de
la nation une obligation de vaccination
qui ne dit pas son nom et la mise en
place d'une société de surveillance
généralisée où chacun vacciner ou non
devra sortir son passeport sanitaire dix
fois par jour pour aller acheter son
pain ou tout simplement aller voir sa
famille quant au non vaccinés qui ont le
droit de ne pas l'être qui ont le droit
de ne pas l'être
ils deviendront de fête des citoyens de
seconde zone a signé un résident à
résidence et ils sont déjà considérés
comme des délinquants alors non non je
ne cautionnerai pas cette vaste
entreprise de division du peuple
français
et c'est dans les yeux en tout cas
j'aurais aimé
ce qui n'est plus gras c'est dans les
yeux que je vous demande monsieur le
ministre de présenter vos excuses au
corps médical que vous avez tenter de
culpabiliser de salir après que ces
pompiers ces médecins ces infirmières
des aides soignantes compte de l'ordre
comptent leurs morts pour avoir été en
première ligne et ce depuis le début
dans cette guerre contre la pandémie en
ayant manqué de tout et par votre faute
vous commettez l'infamie de les
culpabiliser de lady forme et allant
même jusqu'à les menacer de les
licencier s'il ne se soumettait pas à
votre diktat sanitaire mais c'est de la
folie c'est de la folie et c'est
inacceptable alors honte à ce
gouvernement de menteurs de diviseur et
de manipulateur et qui tente de le faire
oublier que le seul responsable de cette
catastrophe sanitaire
c'est lui je ne collabore et pas au
flicage généralisé des citoyens je ne
porterait pas atteinte à leur liberté je
ne contribuerait pas à dresser les
français les uns contre les autres
je vote aurait par conséquent contre ce
projet de passe autoritaire qui
piétinent sans vergogne les valeurs dont
me gargariser que son livre même si
chaque l'égalité et la fraternité
merci la parole est à monsieur le
président claude malhuret pour le groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires réponse six minutes chers
collègues
on va essayer la présidente monsieur
ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues en
écoutant notre collègue ravier j'ai
soudain compris que nous vivions sous le
joug d'une dictature et que sans une
poignée d'héroïque résistants nous ne
nous en serions pas me pas aperçu on
nous a tous inoculé dès notre plus jeune
âge de dt polio est depuis agnès buzyn
cet autocrate rajouter huit vaccins
obligatoires
le carnet de vaccination ancêtre du pass
sanitaire 1 serait un contrôle
généralisé de la population
big brother avait décidé qu'aucun enfant
tenez vous bien ne pouvait entrer à
l'école 107 à ausweis pour parler comme
notre collègue notre droit le plus sacré
à choisir la maladie plutôt que
l'immunité était bafoué depuis pasteur
les français eux mêmes avaient
intériorisé la servitude pensant comme
up ce que seul un léviathan armés de
seringues et aiguilles pouvait les
sauver heureusement comme zorro facebook
et twitter sont arrivés permettant à une
avant garde éclairée de se regrouper
contre le totalitarisme vaccinale après
que durant des années 11 vaccins nous
ait été injecté à l'insu de notre plein
gré au 12e bingo nos yeux se sont
dessinés grâce à ces combattants de la
liberté qui ont eu le courage de nommer
l'infamie du pass sanitaires à part
taille pour florian philippot coup
d'état pour asselineau discrimination
généralisée pour coquerelles et ce soir
enfermement généralisée pour ravier
étoile jaune ou shoah pour les plus
audacieux en définitive la meilleure
preuve des progrès de l'humanité c'est
quand 2500 ans nous sommes passés de
socrate show l'agora à francis lalanne
sur facebook
quel dommage que les réseaux sociaux
n'est pas exister plus tôt pour défendre
contre les dictateurs de l'apli cure la
liberté de mourir en harmonie avec la
nature et ses dons parmi lesquels nos
compagnons toujours la variole la
poliomyélite la peste et le choléra qui
ont permis aux plus grands auteurs camus
juneau thomass man ou d'autres décrire
les chefs-d oeuvre immortelle de la
littérature de pandémie la variole a
disparu le coc vide lui a les chances de
survivre grâce à tous les résistants
numérique qui exigent le droit
d'attraper le virus et de le combattre
comme les polonais de 40 contre les
chars soviétiques à la seule force de
leur poitrine et de leurs mains nues et
le seul secours de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine parfois renforcée par un
médicament redécouvert le ricard les
anciens mouret le poing levé sur les
barricades en chantant l'internationale
nos héros sont prêts à mourir le poing
levé dans les discothèques aux sons de
staying alive
comment ne pas admirer aussi sept
députés et ont fait le choix cornélien
de fausser compagnie à la majorité sans
laquelle elle n'aurait jamais été élu et
de harangues est elle la liberté guidant
le peuple les foules de résistants à la
dictature sanitaire en les invitant
comme henri iv à se rallier à son
panache blanc et d'envahir les
permanences de ses collègues favorables
aux pass sanitaires je voudrais très
sérieusement cette fois imploré qu'on
veut bien nous épargner cette mauvaise
querelle sur les libertés
ce n'est pas le gouvernement le pouvoir
médical où les partisans de la
vaccination obligatoire qu'il et
restreignent
c'est la pandémie loin d'être un viol de
notre liberté les mesures annoncées sont
les conditions de son rétablissement
vaccination accélérer ou confinement
dans deux mois voilà l'alternative
contre est bien comprise la grande
majorité des français qui réalise que
c'est en bornand quelques libertés
aujourd'hui qu'on a une chance d'en
sauver de bien plus précieuse en
septembre c'est donc ce que nous allons
faire et ce choix ne fait pas du
président un dictateur mais un décideur
il ne fait pas du parlement un
rassemblement de tir en mai une
assemblée de responsables
cette décision est elle difficile elle
est au contraire limpide
le vaccin est une prouesse scientifique
que des milliards d'êtres humains
attendent désespérément d'obtenir quel
gouvernement serait assez irresponsable
pour ne pas le proposer à tous le plus
vite possible et protéger en attendant
ce qu'ils ne sont pas encore il ne reste
donc que des questions de méthode
ce qui ne les rend pas plus simple pour
autant et d'abord faut-il choisir la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous ou le
durcissement du pass sanitaires la
première solution al'avantage de
nombreux précédents et de la simplicité
du message
son inconvénient est de ne pouvoir être
achevé avant plusieurs mois
alors que le temps presse philippe bas à
raison l'épidémie flambe de manière
exponentielle les chinois viennent de
découvrir que la charge virale du
variant delta est 1000 fois supérieure à
celle des variants précédent et nous
serons dans quelques jours à 40 ou 50
mille cas quotidiens
le gouvernement a choisi le pass
sanitaire estimant qu'il sera mieux
acceptée et surtout qu'il est
d'application immédiate et enfin qu'il
n'exclut pas le cas échéant la première
solution si l'on se rallient à cette
stratégie et c'est mon cas
il nous reste donc en préciser les
contours les rédacteurs du texte initial
pensant sans doute que pour parler fort
il faut avoir un gros bâton ont eu la
main lourde
le conseil d'état a déjà freiné quelques
ardeurs sur le montant des amendes ou le
droit du travail par exemple
nous devons apporter notre pierre à
l'édifice et en tant qu'élu proche du
terrain faire en sorte que le pass ne
soit pas la première étape de notre plan
de relance industrielle la relance de la
production de paperasserie éviter par
exemple que les terrasses de café ne se
transforme en ring de boxe et que le
train de 8 heures 47 n'ajoute pas deux
heures à ces retards habituels pour
cause de vérifications en matière de
protocole courteline n'est jamais loin
la vaccination pour tous c'est la
liberté pour tous les droits de chacun
doivent être respectées les contraintes
excessives éviter mais à condition de ne
pas mettre en danger la santé d'autrui
et de ne pas oublier que le corollaire
de la liberté c'est la responsabilité
[Musique]
la parole est à monsieur le président
guillaume gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
pour six minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
dames et messieurs les rapporteurs
chaque fois que je suis monté à cette
tribune au nom du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoires j'ai toujours
tenté de conserver une certaine modestie
j'ai toujours souligné l'effroyable
difficultés de votre tâche et je le
confirme encore aujourd'hui et si j'ai
toujours déploré votre méthode de
gouvernance
jamais je me suis opposé à vos choix en
matière de lutte contre le coc vide
j'aurais espéré qu'après un an et demi
de pandémie la difficulté justement de
la tâche
l'imprévisibilité de la situation vous
amenant à 200 pi ternel reniement vous
conduisent et conduisent surtout le
président de la république à un peu plus
de lucidité et de modestie
malheureusement le président pense
toujours comme par exemple pour
l'application stop qu'ovide que pour
reprendre ce mot ce n'est pas un échec
mais ça n'a pas marché alors que la
france est en retard par rapport à ses
voisins sur la vaccination alors que les
doses manque encore pour vacciner les
quelques 20 millions de françaises et de
français qui ne le sont pas alors que le
gouvernement fait mois après mois la
démonstration de ce manque dans 6 pi
tenante ans d'anticipation pardon le
président continue de décider seul de
mesure menace ans gravement les libertés
publiques
madame la ministre nous sommes fatigués
de cette morgue de ce paternalisme de
cette arrogance en vous adressant aux
français comme à des enfants en
admettant jamais vos nombreuses erreurs
en multipliant les propos allant pire te
prend la porte pièce sur les masques les
vaccins le pass and it erp vous
détruisez hélas méthodiquement la valeur
de la parole publique
la défiance qui grandit depuis les
premiers jours du quinquennat atteint
des niveaux invraisemblable comment
convaincre des citoyens et des
citoyennes chauffé à blanc de la
nécessité de se faire vacciner
ils sont tellement exaspérés qu'ils
tombent dans les bras des populismes et
des complotistes les plus abjects qui
usent de comparaison à vomir et aggrave
la fracture de la société
ce cercle vicieux vous n'avez
malheureusement
pas fait grand chose pour le briser loin
de là votre pass and i ter inapplicable
va monter les gens les uns contre les
autres
en réécoutant la fin lunaire de
l'intervention présidentielle
on pourrait presque être amené à penser
que c'est un écran de fumée volontaires
pour pousuivre votre entreprise de casse
sociale
avec la réforme de retraites ou celle de
l'assurance chômage
mais loin de moi l'idée de vous prêter
si funestes intentions
pourtant les résultats sont là la
population est fracturée dans des
proportions alarmantes
or la conquête de l'immunité collective
ne peut passer que par l'adhésion
partager aux objectifs de la campagne
vaccinale
je le dis et le redis au nom de
l'immense majorité des écologistes il
est impératif de convaincre et de
convaincre toute la population de la
nécessité d' al d'aller se faire
vacciner
la voix et le ministre l'a rappelé tout
à l'heure il n'y en a qu'une
elle est bien là pour ce faire quand
allez vous enfin confié à l'assurance
maladie
la charge d'une campagne massive de
sensibilisation sur l'importance de la
vaccination la sécurité des vaccins
les modalités pratiques que
prévoyez-vous pour rapprocher les plus
jeunes de la vaccination
et surtout quelles mesures allez vous
prendre pour déployer enfin la
vaccination dans les quartiers
populaires les inégalités sociales
faveur axe 1 sont criantes et c'est
l'ignorance autant que la défiance qu'il
faut combattre
vous nous permettrait de penser que sans
que l'on comprenne bien pourquoi vous
n'avez pas encore fourni votre effort
comme l'on dit dans le jargon cycliste
dans ces conditions élargir dans de
pareilles proportion est à une telle
vitesse le pass sanitaire est
inacceptable ou ne sait même pas le
temps à celles et ceux qui le souhaitent
de se faire vacciner à temps vous
inspirer le contrôle de tous par tout le
monde
avec un dispositif juridiquement bancale
malgré les alertes du conseil d'état et
du défenseur des droits
vous imposer des amendes délirante
équivalent à celles pour l'usurpation
d'identité par exemple dans le même
temps faisant fi des recommandations
sanitaires vous autorisez l'abandon du
mas dans les lieux sous
parce sanitaires au passage vous écorner
encore le droit du travail
tout ça pour ne pas rendre obligatoire
la vaccination ce n'est pas forcément
notre position mais force est de
constater que cela aurait été plus
simple et moins liberticide et comme
d'habitude vous n'écoutez rien ni
personne vous avez fait passer tout ce
que vous pouviez par décret en urgence
vous nous soumettez le reste par
obligation dans des conditions d'examen
déplorable même si on peut les
comprendre que l'urgence ne saurait
justifier vous n'écoutez aucune de vos
positions
même quand elles sont toutes d'accord
contre vous vous ne consultez pas où
vous faites semblant vous n'associez que
très peu les collectivités les
collectivités locales
contrairement à ce que vous semblez
croire tout cela ne nous fait pas gagner
en efficacité très loin de là hélas bien
des régimes parlementaires et en
commencer par l'allemagne enregistrent
de meilleurs résultats que nous dans la
gestion de l'épidémie sans s'asseoir sur
la délibération démocratique
alors madame la ministre j'espère que
vous retiendrez au moins les apports de
bon sens du sénat s'agissant notamment
des mesures d'isolement pour les
écologistes en l'état cela reste
insuffisant
ce texte est vecteur de trop d'atteintes
aux libertés publiques trop de promesses
bafouées de trop de divisions nous
appelons le gouvernement à mettre le
paquet sur la stratégie vaccinale plutôt
que de contraintes trop but rate trop
brutalement et divisé nous appelons
enfin à lever les brevets sur les
vaccins et à favoriser leur diffusion
mondiale
tous les efforts que nous faisons toutes
les restrictions que nous imposons ne
trouveront pas de fin tant que nous
permettront au virus de circuler
largement dans le monde tant qu'il
luttera et que les variants apparu aux
quatre coins du monde résistant à nos
vaccins reviendront frapper à notre
porte
l'égoïsme vaccinale des pays occidentaux
les gestions national du coc vides sont
des impasses sanitaires il est grand
temps de sortie de cannes national pour
enrayer enfin la pandémie on espère
qu'au delà du soutien de nos sportifs
le président macron profitera de son
déplacement à tokyo pour oeuvrer en ce
sens merci merci
la parole est à monsieur alain richard
pour le groupe du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
pour sept minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur madame et monsieur
pardon et président de commission et mes
chers collègues je crois que en ouvrant
ce débat nous devons garder notre
attention sur la très forte mutabilité
de la situation sanitaire depuis 18 mois
nous découvrons avec une très faible un
très faible des les anticipations des
variations importantes à la fois des
types de virus et de leur manière de se
propager et tout en observant leur
prudence et parfois leurs divergences
nous voyons bien que les chercheurs
s'attendent à ce que nous ayons de
nouvelles situations imprévues il faut
donc que new delhi berio avec la
prudence le pragmatisme de cette
difficulté à anticiper et de cette
largeur des anticipations possible et
c'est la raison pour laquelle tout en
comprenant évidemment le la satisfaction
de collecte trouve que nous sommes
amenés à délibérer rapidement que ça
fait partie du devoir de responsables
publics et parlementaires le sont tout
autant que l'exécutif de devoir
s'adapter dans leur travail dans leur
mission à des situations qui présente
une urgence qui présente une nécessité
je crois que là les mesures que nous
sommes montés en train de décider en
train d'adopter ont pour double objectif
de protéger toute la population est de
maintenir le maximum d'activités
sociales devant un contexte qui donc est
en train d'évoluer
il me semble donc il faut que nous
montrions favorables à une large palette
de mesures possibles de limitation de
freinage
de la diffusion du virus pour une durée
suffisante et ce sera donc ma différence
d'appréciation rixe qui a expliqué tout
à l'heure philippe bas il vaut mieux que
nous ayons ces mesures à disposition
pour une durée plus large en sachant que
l'exécutif sera amené à en faire un
emploi proportionnée le ministre a été
tout à fait explicites sur ce point et
que bien entendu au jour le jour
cet emploi des différentes prérogatives
sera sous le contrôle du parlement et
dialoguer avec lui donc de ce point de
vue je crois que nous serons très
nombreux
en tout cas dans notre groupe ce sera le
cas de tous a approuvé l'exigence de
vaccination pour des motifs
professionnels non seulement des
professions du soin dans une définition
à ce lave mais dans les autres activités
qui comporte un contacts intensifs avec
le public et ses obligations comporte
des sanctions sur lesquels nous devrons
apporter les adoucissement les
atténuations et notamment les délais qui
sont nécessaires dans une dans une
démocratie sociale mais fixer des
obligations d'intérêt public aussi
majeur sans les assortir de sanctions
serait également un recul devant la
responsabilité de passes sanitaire c'est
vrai est une contrainte sociale
mais l'intérêt général non nous sommes
les gardiens doit prévaloir
et donc si c'est la condition du
maintien des activités
je reviens au dilemme que nous présenter
le ministre tout à l'heure c'est à dire
le risque d'avoir sinon à basculer vers
les fermetures vers les confinements en
tout cas les fermetures d'activités nous
oblige à regarder ce dossier en face et
c'est vrai qu'il n'a qu'il a pour effet
de favoriser ceux qui ont choisi le
vaccin de façon précoce et c'est vrai
que sur le choix des dates exactes
madame monsieur nice devront et vous y
êtes prêts
ça durera jusqu'à la fin de la navette
nous devons envisager d adaptation parce
que au moment où des centaines de
milliers de personnes par jour sont
vaccinés nous sommes à l'heure actuelle
en capacités certaines semaines de faire
trois millions de vaccinations dans la
semaine mais il faut tout de même le
délai pour avoir les deux doses le choix
exacte des dates à partir desquels
s'appliquent les mesures de fermeture ou
en tout cas de l'imposition du pass
sanitaires sont un choix délicat mais
devant l'urgence la rapidité de la
montée de la décomptabilisation ne
pouvons pas non plus trop tergiverser
dont il y aura des fois que nous allons
faire ensemble de temps d'adaptation
pragmatique de manière à accompagner la
montée du dollar montée du flux
vaccinable je souhaite aussi de rendre
le gouvernement attentif à une
proposition de philippe à de notre
rapporteur sur l'utilisation des
sanctions administratives en priorité
par rapport aux sanctions pénales
je crois que typiquement une
intervention publique comme une mesure
de santé publique se prête plus à des
mesures d'autorité administrative sous
un contrôle que nous connaissons bien
compris le le contrôle en référé quasi
instantanée du tribunal administratif
dont il n'y a pas du tout de déni de
justice
mais l'art habilité d'application et le
caractère je dirais direct delà de la
mise en vigueur de mesures par exemple
de fermeture administrative d'activité
lorsque visiblement de façon contrôlée
par la force publique les personnes
assujetties à ces obligations ne sont
pas respectées est à mon avis une
approche plus efficace et d'une certaine
façon aussi moins coûteuse que l'
approche uniquement par delà les mesures
judiciaires
est-ce que nous terminerons par
l'obligation de vaccination que général
je le crois exactement pour les mêmes
raisons énoncées tout à l'heure par
claude malhuret c'est à dire que nous
n'avons pas de raisons nous effarouchées
d'une obligation vaccinale
supplémentaires alors qu'il y en a
depuis un chèque l'ennemi enfin pas tout
à fait un siècle un quart applicable
dans ce pays et qu'elles ont rempli des
des objectifs d'intérêt général
absolument eve aveuglante donc il ne me
semble pas que nous devions reculer
devant cette décision simplement par
rapport à nos collègues qui pense que
c'est la solution immédiate
comme il nous reste probablement une
bonne quinzaine de millions d'injections
à faire pour arriver à un taux de
couverture suffisante entre les gens qui
n'ont pas encore eu leur première dose
et les gens qui ont eu la première mais
doivent attendre la seconde daste aurait
cette obligation à l'instant et de ne
pas pouvoir la contrôler avant plusieurs
mois serait me semble-t-il pas la
solution efficace et le contenu je crois
qu'il est préférable que nous gardions
cette décision pour un nouveau choix qui
sera à faire en tant que législateur
plus tard dans l'année
alors que nous aurons espérons le et en
tout cas tout est fait pour cela atteint
le maximum d'efficacité des mesures dont
nous discutons ce soir merci la parole
est à madame véronique guillotin pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen et pour six minutes cher
collègue madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la présidente de
commission madame la rapporteure
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
pardon chers collègues ils se croyaient
libre et personne ne sera jamais libre
tant qu'il y aura des fléaux cette
phrase l'élu il ya quelques jours dans
le train d'ailleurs issu d'un du
chef-d'oeuvre d'albert camus la paix ce
couac plus en phase avec ce que l'on vit
aujourd'hui elle illustre le difficile
équilibre entre les libertés et la
protection de la santé entre les
libertés individuelles et l'intérêt
général
des débats qui nous anime maintenant
depuis le début de la pandémie
dix-huit mois et neuf projets doit plus
tard nous n'en sommes toutefois plus au
même point aujourd'hui nous avons le
vaccin nous avons un espoir et cette
chance inouïe de disposer de plusieurs
millions de doses proposé gratuitement à
la population faut-il le rappeler
pendant que comme le disait mon collègue
bernard fialaire dans de nombreux pays
n'ayant pas atteint notre degré de
développement nombreux les réclames ou
meurt de ne pas les avoir reçus je pense
bien sûr aux tunisiens qui connaissent
des heures sombres et à qui nous
exprimons ici toute notre amitié et
notre solidarité
pendant qu'ils comptent leurs morts
faute de bouteilles d'oxygène et de
vaccins en nombre suffisant nous en
sommes toujours à débattre de
l'efficacité et de la sécurité de la
vaccination
bien sûr il faut écouter ceux qui
doutent les sceptiques les réticents il
faut dialoguer avec eux faire preuve de
pédagogie leur dire que toutes les
phases de tests et les procédures
d'autorisation sont respectés que la
pharmacovigilance assure une
surveillance continuelle des éventuels
effets secondaires le soin malgré tout
restent basées sur la confiance et la
médecine sur des faits scientifiques
qu'on ne peut balayer sur la base de
supputations sans fondement mais il faut
aussi être intraitable vis-à-vis des
plus virulents ceux qui dégradent les
centres de vaccination qui menacent ceux
qui travaillent qui compare notre pays à
une dictature et notre système de santé
à la shoah
ceux là on franchit résolument la ligne
rouge de la décence aujourd'hui tout le
monde s'improvise virologues
infectiologues et les réseaux sociaux
amplifie le phénomène
personne n'a l'obligation de tout
maîtriser ou de tout comprendre on a par
contre l'obligation éthique et morale de
se forger un avis à partir des faits et
en matière de fait la vaccination nous
protègent contre les formes graves du
virus est en limite la circulation la
quasi absence des patients vaccinés en
réanimation en témoigne l'immunité
collective est un objectif vers lequel
deux
vont tendre et les mesures de ce texte y
contribuer face à l'arrivée ces variants
delta dont la charge virale est
multiplié par 1000 et qu'il ya un taux
de contamination 60% de plus élevé nous
devons malheureusement et urgemment car
il ya urgence prendre de nouvelles
mesures si nous ne vous si nous voulons
contenir une quatrième vague qui risque
de nous submerger et nous obligerait au
confinement ce que personne ne souhaite
cette pandémie par sa violence et son
extraordinaire résistance nous impose
des ajustements perpétuelle les
nouvelles mesures de ce texte en choque
certains du nombre de mails qu'on reçoit
dans nos boîtes car elles contraignent
l'accès aux activités du quotidien alors
lui ces ajustements touche à certaines
de nos libertés individuelles
mais l'état un devoir de protection et
ce n'est pas lui qui prive de liberté
mais le virus en priorité cette
protection s'est jusqu'ici manifestés
par des pertes de confinement et de
couvre-feu aggravant à chaque fois la
lassitude des français et la situation
économique de notre pays et ses mesures
de confinement et de couvre feu sont
bien plus privatif de liberté que le
pass sanitaire qui nous est proposé
néanmoins l'extension du pass à lyster
et l'obligation vaccinale doivent
s'accompagner de garde fous les délais
imposés pour le pass and i ter et
l'obligation vaccinale paraissent bien
court si l'on veut un statut vaccinal
complet au 15 septembre il faudra avoir
reçu sa première dose avant le 18 août
or certains centres ne propose pas de
créneau avant fin août à ce sujet le
conviendrez madame la ministre de
confirmer que les personnes soumises à
l'obligation vaccinale auront un accès
prioritaire aux vaccins afin qu'elle
puisse se mettre en règle au plus vite
nous devons privilégier l'incitation et
récompenser ceux qui se sont engagés
dans la démarche de la vaccination
quand on sait que l'immunité acquise et
forte des trois semaines après la
première injection une tolérance ne
pourrait-elle pas être accordé aux primo
vacciner pour les plus récalcitrants
nous devons bien sûr jamais renoncé à
expliquer rassurer accompagner mais
malgré les efforts de pédagogie qui sont
réalisés le taux de vaccination et c'est
une réalité taux de vaccination de la
population et des soignants demeure
insuffisant l'obligation à petit maxime
à vaccinale n'est pas une stigmatisation
comme on l'entend souvent elles existent
déjà avec le vaccin contre l'hépatite b
évolue en fonction de la situation
sanitaire
elle vise à protéger les soignants
d'abord mais aussi à répondre comme le
disait notre rapporteur à leur devoir
d'exemplarité leurs devoirs éthiques
vis-à-vis des personnes vulnérables qui
s'engagent à protéger au quotidien
je suis donc favorable vous l'aurez
compris à l'obligation vaccinale
proposerai même de l'étendre à d'autres
professions je m'interroge par ailleurs
sur les conditions de contrôle du poste
sanitaire dans les restaurants et les
cafés je serais favorable à ce que cette
responsabilité porte sur le consommateur
plutôt que sur l'exploitant et que les
contrôles soient faits par des personnes
habilitées pour le faire enfin je ne
peux terminer mon propos sans évoquer ce
délai si court qui nous octroyait pour
l'examen de mesures d'une telle
importance
sinon marges de manoeuvre sont comme
souvent limités nous aurions tout de
même apprécié pouvoir prendre le temps
de la réflexion et du débat toutefois
vous l'aurez compris madame la ministre
je partage la philosophie du texte et la
nécessité de ces mesures en freinant en
faveur du freinage de la circulation
virale et du déploiement massif de la
vaccination
merci la parole est à madame la
présidente eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes et pour six minutes cher
collègue madame la présidente madame la
ministre est cher collègue
d'emblée je souhaite vivement contesté
la précipitation de ce débat qui ne
permet pas d'examiner sérieusement les
dispositions proposées qui ont
d'ailleurs évolué au fil des jours et je
ne développe pas ici sur les travaux de
nos commissions des lois et des affaires
sociales qui nous oblige à travailler
dans des conditions à la limite de
l'acceptable temps pour les élus que
pour les personnels nos collaboratrices
et nos collaborateurs
madame la ministre vous faire offense je
dois vous dire aussi que je regrette
profondément le départ du ministre
monsieur verrons
je ne sais comment nous devons
interpréter ce départ précipité sans
même prendre le temps d'écouter la
discussion générale et particulièrement
les interventions des groupes
chers collègues nous sommes pleinement
conscients des dangers que fait courir
le vario delta mais nous devons accepter
ou vous devez accepter de débattre
d'autres chemins existants que celui
proposé par le président de la
république la démocratie le pluralisme
c'est savoir écouter prendre en compte
et parfois a concédé et reconnaître ses
erreurs oui nous savons que le variant
delta se répand vite et nous le savons
depuis de nombreuses semaines
oui nous savons qu'en france les
contaminations repartent vivement à la
hausse
nous savons aussi que la vaccination est
le rempart efficace qui évite les
hospitalisations et les réanimations la
vaccination est un outil formidable pour
permettre de venir à bout de l'épidémie
et à ce titre nous demandons que le
vaccin soit reconnu comme grande cause
nationale et mondiale et donc que les
brevets soit levée mais il faut des
moyens pour aller au plus près de la
population non vaccinée souvent par un
abandon sociale ou par manque
d'information informé convaincre
mobiliser tous les acteurs de la société
sont la clé d'une vaccination pour tous
c'était peu ou prou la position de
monsieur verront alors pourquoi un tel
revirement
comment ne pas être surpris par cette
volonté soudaine de culpabiliser notre
patte de le diviser de l'euphrate
fracturée c'est monsieur vers en lui
même qui a refusé les vaccinodromes en
janvier dernier
c'est lui qui a fait le choix d'une
vaccination progressif de la population
rappelant durant des semaines que les
jeunes ne risquait pas tant et pouvait
attendre qui a fait le choix de
commandes est massivement astrazeneca
typhus sévèrement critiqué jusqu'à être
interdit dans plusieurs pays
la campagne fac vaccinale fut même
suspendu en france si si mal à me en mai
en juin
la vaccination a décollé la suspicion a
reculé mais qu'at-il était fait pour
organiser la vaccination de
durant les congés face à la déferlante
du darian delta quelle mouche a piqué le
gouvernement pour dégainer un projet de
loi aussi attentatoire aux libertés
publiques
de plus pourquoi produire un
argumentaire plus pas billy thater à
outrance alors que les doses ne sont pas
disponibles pour parvenir rapidement à
l'immunité collective
madame la ministre notre analyse que
nous développerons au cours des débats
et celle ci ce projet doit le discours
d' emmanuel macron est un aveu d'échec
manifeste notre peuple n'est pas assez
vacciner non pas parce qu'il est
récalcitrant mais parce que vous n'avez
pas mis en oeuvre les moyens nécessaires
ensuite et en même temps le président de
la république utilise moment pour
accentuer la dérive autoritaire de son
pouvoir pour placer pour le placer sous
une cloche libéral le 12 juillet pour
placer notre pays sous une cloche libéré
le 2 juillet manuel maquereau a mêlé sa
nouvelle réponse sécuritaire à la crise
sanitaire à la confirmation ou
l'annnonce de coup de force anti sociaux
à travers cette intervention
l'autoritarisme apparaît comme le point
commun à ces différents aspects de la
politique du pouvoir actuel la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire du 30 septembre au 31 décembre
2021 symbolise le maintien d'un état
d'exception l'instauration du pass
sanitaire est un outil de division de
notre peuple
le respect du droit de l'égalité sont à
préserver la défenseure des droits comme
d'innombrables juriste associations
syndicats c'est d'ailleurs vivement
inquiété et a annoncé dix
recommandations précises importante pour
préserver les libertés le droit face à
vos propositions
j'aimerais connaître votre réponse
détaillée à ces interpellations
le pass sanitaire est selon nous vicié
dès le départ
qui dit parce sanitaire dix contrôles
d'identité madame la ministre
soit vous faites contrôler l'identité
par des personnes non assermentés et
c'est une dérive inacceptable
soit vous permettez d'intensifier les
contrôles de police inopinées dans les
restaurants dans les cinémas dans les
salles de sport dans les transports ou à
domicile dans le cadre du contrôle de
l'isolément est ce un modèle de société
que vous portez une société de suspicion
de contrôle permanent vous fait ce choix
nous nous faisons le choix de la
confiance
delas et de la santé publique le pass
sanitaires pour nos concitoyens sera une
obligation pour la vie quotidienne pour
d'autres ce sera une obligation au
travail nous refusons que la suspension
ou le licenciement soit l'aboutissement
de cette obligation mieux professionnels
concernant les soignants nous comprenons
le débat sur l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants mais pourquoi là aussi la
menace de la suspension et du
licenciement
l'obligation d'isolement que j'évoquais
pose également de lourds problèmes de
droits nous refusons qu'une mesure
privative de liberté car c'est de cela
dont il s'agit
puisse résulter d'un tel d'un seul test
positif sans décision de justice
par ailleurs comment ne pas constater
une nouvelle fois la discrimination à
l'égard des moins favorisés qui ne
peuvent respecter d'isolement du fait
des conditions de logement précaire
enfin madame la ministre
comment ne pas s'alarmer du changement
de donne concernant le système
d'information dépistages le cidep qui
réservé aux personnels de santé sera
consultable demain par toutes les
catégories des habilités à effectuer les
contrôles la préservation des données
personnelles et le secret médical sont
foulés aux pieds par votre projet
madame la ministre nous voterons contre
votre projet même proviseur même
provisoirement assouplie par le sénat
car sous le couvert d'un combat pour la
vaccination il accélère un projet de
société attentatoires aux libertés et
droits des salariés sans armes et
d'autres pays face aux pandémies
merci
la parole est à monsieur philippe
bonnecarrère pour le groupe union
centriste pour dix minutes chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame des
ministres mesdames madame la présidente
déchue président madame et monsieur le
rapporteur les chers collègues
les sénateurs centristes à bord de le
débat sur la réponse à la crise
sanitaire avec deux lignes directrices
la première notre priorité est la
vaccination complété par le maintien des
gestes d'arrière la deuxième est la
défense des libertés une responsabilité
traditionnelle du sénat avec une
expression pour la plupart d'entre nous
du pass sanitaire mais dans un cadre
nettement plus resserrée en refusant
d'alimenter une passion française pour
le droit pénal ou de menacés de
licenciement là où la suspension du
contrat de travail et des salaires nous
semble déjà très suffisant quelques mots
sur notre diagnostic la crise ducobu 19
dure depuis 18 mois
la maladie est installée probablement
pour longtemps et le virus ne connaît
pas les frontières
nous avons demandé hier matin au
professeur delfraissy de nous aider à
nous projeter sur le long terme il nous
a exprimé les doutes les incertitudes de
la communauté scientifique et présenter
les deux thèse privilégiée pour les
optimistes après une vaccination
généralisée
le virus continue à évoluer peut-être
une ou deux mutations encore tout en
perdant progressivement sa capacité à
contaminer ou plus simplement sa
dangerosité pour les pessimistes le
virus pourrait connaître de nouveaux
variants à échappement vaccinale pour
utiliser cette terminologie continuant à
faire évoluer conduisant alors à faire
évoluer les vaccins au fur et à mesure
pessimiste ou optimiste
une forme de normalité si vous me
permettez l'expression de la présence du
virus s'impose n comment pouvons-nous
gérer cette normalité de la présence du
virus
parmi nous la réponse nécessite de
choisir entre des mauvaises ou très
mauvaises solutions
nous abordons cette question avec
humilité en étant conscients que nous
sommes dans une société sinon de peur au
minimum de défiance ou l'émotion
l'emportent régulièrement sur la
rationalité et où l'individualisme a
souvent vous le savez bien le pas sur le
collectif
ceci nous conduit à ne pas troupe asséné
de vérité a exprimé des réponses mesuré
dont nous devons admettre qu'elles
pourront évoluer à cultiver finalement
une éthique du doute et du respect des
opinions
la réponse chers collègues en termes de
santé publique est connue ont indiqué en
préambule la vaccination couplée aux
gestes dits barrière les vaccins ont été
trouvés ils sont entre nos mains
ils sont disponibles gratuit est proposé
à toute la population
notre débat ce soir est typiquement 101
discourtois une forme de débat de riches
vaccinons et nous avons le recul puisque
souvent cette question nous est posée
de plus de 3 milliards de vaccination
déjà réalisé à travers le monde nous
n'avons pas d'alternative sérieuse leur
tour un confinement serait un drame et
il n'y a pas plus de solutions
disponibles vous le serré sous forme de
médicaments tenant aussi compte du fait
que nous sommes dans une société où
chaque lit est essentielle il n'est pas
possible de raisonner sur une forme
d'acceptation dans nombre de morts ou de
malades graves
même s'il est interdire au camp de nous
d'avoir une réflexion sur la place de la
spiritualité ou d'une forme de
transcendance dans le contexte du
variant delta et de l'accélération des
contaminations
la vaccination est le maintien
complémentaire des gestes derrière son
jeu vous lisez pour les sénateurs
centristes la priorité il reste en eau
faire la traduction en termes de règles
de
public et deux solutions s'ouvre alors à
nous la vaccination obligatoire générale
ou le pass sanitaire la vaccination
obligatoire générale a le mérite de
répondre clairement à l'enjeu de santé
publique santé vaccinations
c'est clair précis conforme à une
passion française celle de l'égalité
c'est aussi pédagogique le gouvernement
ne propose pas cette solution
la question me posait plusieurs mes
prédécesseurs ont reformulé également
cet argument qui essaient de
l'acceptabilité sociale le souhaitable
chers collègues est il possible est ce
que nos concitoyens vont accepter une
telle mesure
comment l'état le fera t elle respectée
et si la vaccination de diane est
obligatoire
les tangages dorée évidemment sa
crédibilité sur l'exécution de ces
dispositions
nous n'écartons pensé pendant chers
collègues en ce qui concerne notre
groupe à terme de devoir envisager la
vaccination obligatoire générale c'est
une question nous semble-t-il de
calendrier et les vrais observations
critiques qui ont été formulées à
l'égard de cette solution vous l'avez
entendu au fur et à mesure des
interventions sont plus liés à un risque
d'engorgement à la rentrée des demandes
de vaccination mais je pense qu'il faut
garder cela dans nos perspectives
la proposition de rendre obligatoire la
vaccination des soignants ne fait aucune
difficulté dans notre groupe nous
considérons qu'il s'agit de la simple
application de règles éthiques
c'est aussi une question de confiance
dans notre pacte social
reste la question du passé ni terre
lepage sanitaire dans c'est l'été qui
est telle qu'il nous avait été présentée
telle que ceux ci nous avait été dit et
répété pour nous convaincre de donner
notre accord dans le cadre de ce qui
allait devenir la loi du 21 mai mais
bien sûr plus d'actifs d'aig d'actualité
ce qui n'est pas un élément favorisant
la confiance
est-ce qu'ils portent atteinte à ce que
le passé ni terre porte atteinte aux
libertés
oui est-ce qu'ils portent atteinte
gravement aux libertés oui également à
la fois par leur étendue et peut-être et
surtout par une forme de banalisation
à l'occasion de ce qui était même notre
quatre autres 14e période d'état
d'urgence depuis 2015 est ce que cette
atteinte est proportionnelle aux risques
c'est notre interrogation et notre sujet
avec pour le gouvernement
l'argument d'urgence on a entendu les
chiffres qui nous ont été données au
regard des évolutions du var ya du
variant delta et le sera rapporteur vous
avez rappelé les questions de charge
virale et de rapidité de transmission à
l'assemblée nationale le pass and i ter
a été décrit comme un outil de liberté
une incitation à se dessiner pour
permettre à chacun d'entre nous d'avoir
une vie normale
c'est psychologiquement efficace et les
prises de rendez-vous mais six en vue de
la vaccination dans les heures qui ont
suivi d'interventions du président l'ont
démontré je voudrais cependant à de
sévères tensions
chers collègues sur la limite de cet
exercice c'est en tout cas la
contradiction ou l'ambiguïté du pass
sanitaire il nous est proposée à titre
incitatif pour favoriser la vaccination
alors que sa vocation devrait être
sanitaire
le pass and i ter n'est pas inverse de
la vaccination une réponse en tant que
tel de santé publique
le pass and i ter ne soigne pas il peut
le devenir
s'il contribue à réduire le brassage
social et ainsi les risques de
transmission c'est sa justification
ce qui veut dire que les prises de
parole madame le ministre régulière des
ministres depuis l'intervention du
président de la république à chaque une
prise de parole on nous annonce un
assouplissement supplémentaire ou une
suppression d'un irritant
que l'on a pu déceler si
l'assouplissement en assouplissement et
je sais bien qu'il y aura des
amendements en ce sens de coup de rabot
en coup de rabot le pass and i ter n'a
plus de vocation sanitaire et n'a plus
qu'un rôle incitatif
il n'a plus alors de fondement ou
n'aurait plus alors de fondement
juridique de fond de manque de force de
fondement pardon constitutionnel je
serai bien sûr prudent quant à la
position que prendra le conseil
constitutionnel mais ne sous-estimons
pas tout à fait cet aspect des choses où
ce risque dans notre débat où est passé
j'en terminerai par là le débat
défenseurs des libertés
notre deuxième ligne directrice il est
bien là dans le travail de la commission
des lois et des affaires sociales avec
ses rapporteurs philippe bas et chantal
des scènes j'insiste sur le changement
de logiciel en décidant que nous serons
si le texte est voté dans un état
d'urgence sanitaire et non dans un
régime dans un régime de sortie
nous marquons par définition l'exception
et son caractère temporaire
je rajouterais bien sûr tout le volet
d'encadrement avec les questions date le
31 octobre le compte rendu hebdomadaire
la fermeture administrative plutôt que
les sanctions pénales
l'isolément avec un suivi par les agents
de la cpam l'absence d'accès au dossier
par les services préfectoraux la
suspension du contrat plutôt que le
licenciement j'attirais enfin votre
attention
madame le ministre sur une forme de
maladresse dans les propos de monsieur
benglis dans les propos introductifs de
l'ancien ministre dans la mesure où il a
insisté sur les points de désaccord à
venir avec le sénat j'espère que cette
maladresse ragots mais demain si vous
souhaiter parvenir à une cmp positive
si la parole est à madame monique lubin
pour le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains pour six minutes cher
collègue madame la présidente madame la
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs et président de commission
madame la ministre l'examen du projet de
loi relatif à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire se fait dans un agenda
excessivement contre un signe à notre
avis d'un manque d'anticipation de votre
part qui donne une impression de chaos
au moment où nous avons tous
collectivement besoin d'un cap clair
nous sommes convaincus au sein du groupe
socialistes et écologistes et
républicains du sénat que vous en
viendrez nécessairement à la position
qui est la nôtre car pour nous le seul
chemin aujourd'hui envisageables pour
prendre la main sur l'épidémie est celui
d'une vaccination universelle
nous faisons ce choix pour que chacun
puisse être protégé et protège les siens
tout en jouissant de ses droits
fondamentaux
plusieurs institutions du champ
scientifique et médicale se sont d'ores
et déjà prononcée en faveur de
l'obligation vaccinale généralisée c'est
le cas notamment de l'académie nationale
de médecine le 19 juillet dernier jour
de présentation en conseil des ministres
du présent projet de loi
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que
l'académie s'était prononcé publiquement
pour le port du masque d avril 2020
quand le gouvernement soutenait tang
core qu'il ne servait à rien en
population générale
nous espérons cependant que votre
alignement sur ses positions
n'interviendra pas trop tard en
attendant nous voici contraint de
travailler à une politique qui menace
d'être inopérante incohérente et
liberticide et c'est si flagrant que
vous vous retrouver dans la position de
devoir procéder aux ajustements sur
ajustements dans l'espoir de consolider
un édifice de plus en plus bancal c'est
tout particulièrement le cas pour les
modalités relatives à l'instauration
n'aime pas sanitaire qui aboutit à la
stigmatisation des professionnels
intervenant dans le secteur de la santé
vous créez une nouvelle obligation
vaccinale
mais pour certaines catégories
professionnelles uniquement avec un
système de sanctions parfois très
lourdes qui pourrait s'avérer
contre-productif vous le faites en
dehors de tout cadre de santé publics
existants parce que cette obligation
n'existe pas dans le code de la santé
publique
mis bout à bout cela pourrait bien
devenir une usine à gaz
la définition du périmètre de votre
dispositif est particulièrement large
les critères étant floue à la limite
d'un certain arbitraire sont visés par
l'obligation que vous mettez en place
des catégories de personnes définies par
leur profession mais aussi par leur lieu
d'exercice professionnel
nous sommes confrontés à une sorte
d'inventaire à la prévert allant des
aides à domicile aux sapeurs pompiers en
passant par les élèves le psychanalyste
et c'est en revanche policiers et
professeurs ne sont pas concernées par
cette obligation vaccinale alors même
que ces derniers travaillent tout
particulièrement en contact avec des
publics au sein desquels la circulation
du virus est forte et incontrôlée signe
du caractère hasardeux de votre démarche
vous prenez le risque de fracture et la
société française en désignant des
professionnels qui pourrait tendre plus
faire l'objet d'un traitement
différencié évoluant au gré des
rectifications que vous y apporterez le
gouvernement a en effet introduit une
nouvelle disposition annoncée la veille
par la ministre du travail
la possibilité pour le salarié de
convenir avec son employeur de prendre
des rtt ou les jours de congés pour
éviter une suspension du contrat de
travail
c'est dire si la mesure initiale était
pertinente vous vous donnez beaucoup de
mal et vous m'ont donné beaucoup de mal
pour imposer sans le dire une
vaccination généralisée dans cette
pandémie qui n'en finit pas le courage
politique consisterait à dire à tous les
français qu'ils doivent obligatoirement
se faire vacciner quels que soient leur
environnement professionnel
le courage politique serait d'affirmer
que se faire vacciner pose un acte de
solidarité de fraternité même en ce
qu'il induit l'intérêt de l'autre au
delà de son intérêt propre et en skill
position l'individu non pas comme une
pièce unique et autocentrée et comme un
citoyen conscient du rôle qu'il doit
jouer dans un moment crucial pour le
groupe auquel il appartient
le courage politique serait d'assumer
une dessine une décision de vacciner
sur universel obligatoire qui
permettrait d'assurer la concorde au
sein de la société française
ce ne sont pas les libertés publiques
que l'on doit combattre la liberté de
circulation et d'accéder aux biens et
services l'égalité de traitement la
protection contre l'arbitraire ne sont
pas la maladie nous ne voulons pas
d'impasse liberticide
nous voulons atteindre l'immunité
collective elle est fixé un taux de
population vaccinée contre le coc u19 de
90 % du fait des variants en circulation
et tout particulièrement du variant
delta nous nous inscrivons également
dans une démarche de santé publique
claire assise sur nos connaissances
médicales et scientifiques
elle nous évitera le glissement vers des
pratiques de surveillance sociale
générale pointés par la défenseure des
droits et vers l'extension attentatoires
aux libertés du pass sanitaires à tous
les gestes de la vie quotidienne
c'est une politique de santé publique
dont nous avons besoin aujourd'hui nous
voulons les mesures et les textes
pertinents
nous voulons les moyens humains et
budgétaires nécessaires pour lutter
contre cette maladie et assurer la
protection sociale cela constitue une
démarche de lutte contre les inégalités
territoriales et sociales car elle crée
un devoir de l'état d'aller vers les
publics les plus éloignés de la
vaccination sans moyens supplémentaires
les mesures envisagées s'avéreront
encore plus dur pour les publics
précaires dont on sait que ce sont ceux
qui ont le moins accès au vaccin
nous sommes confrontés à un problème de
santé qui remet fondamentalement en
cause les équilibres de la société le
pays après à des efforts fusse-t-il
coûteux il l'a démontré depuis un an
poursuivre l'objectif de vaccination
obligatoire universel sans l'assumer
c'est autre chose c'est le pire des
choix nous avons ces masques et avec
l'outil pervers du pass sanitaire
imposante en la dissimulant une
obligation vaccinale généraliser le
caractère trouble de votre démarche est
perçu par la population elle suscite un
rejet qui met non seulement en péril
l'efficacité de la politique de la lutte
contre la copie de 19 mais aussi les
assises de notre système politique tout
entier
aujourd'hui plus que jamais nous avons
besoin de solidarité et d'unité et cela
passe nécessairement par la vaccination
on généralise et il la parole est à mme
c'est le président bruno retailleau pour
le groupe l'est républicain et pour 19
minutes cher collègue madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
madame monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues il faut se rendre à l'évidence
nous sommes confrontés à une quatrième
vague mais pas encore au pic de cette
quatrième vague qui viendra sans doute
dans quelques semaines les chiffres qui
ont ici été cités sont spectaculaires le
cap des vingt mille cas a été franchi un
juriste qui était ultra minoritaire au
mois de mai -2 1% des contaminations
devient ultra dominant dans quelques
semaines il sera sans doute au-delà de
90% des contaminations est un virus qui
certes a moins d'impact pour le moment
sur les hospitalisations mais je veux
citer un chiffre qui n'a pas encore été
c'est qu'en une semaine les
hospitalisations ont augmenté en france
de 70 % certes en passant d'un niveau
bas mais il y à une augmentation qui est
préoccupante
c'est un virus retors très retors avec
finalement une stratégie de survie
incroyablement perfectionner parce que
tout se passe tout se passe comme si ce
virus par ces mutations compenser le
rétrécissement de sa cible parce qu'il
ya de plus en plus dans le monde de
personnes vaccinées
tout se passe comme si ils compensaient
ce rétrécissement de sa cible par une
plus forte contagiosité
et lorsque la commission des affaires
sociales a auditionné il ya quelques
jours le professeur delfraissy qui l'a
cité d'ailleurs cette charge mille fois
supérieur au premier variant c'est un
chiffre qui est stupéfiant
il faut
se rendre à l'évidence mes chers
collègues nous n'en avons pas terminé
avec cette pandémie
la stratégie de vaccination elle est
essentielle j'y reviendrai elle n'est
pas unique
en revanche il y a eu les annonces du
président de la république la semaine
dernière quand eu un double effet
positif et négatif positif puisque on
voit bien qu'il ya eu un formidable
déclic chez beaucoup de nos compatriotes
qui étaient dans un entre-deux sans
doute dans une position très attentiste
mais aussi ne nous cachons pas il y a eu
comme une sorte de poussée d'archimède
en sens inverse un raidissement une
sorte de vent de colère et on a vu des
manifestations dans les rues
alors madame la ministre l'exercice que
vous lui demandez ce soir est un
exercice pour nous qui sommes votre
opposition à ces redoutables
pas seulement parce que les conditions
de travail malheureusement nous
finissons par nous y habituer sont
détestables trop rapide trop précipités
pour faire un travail sérieux et dieu
sait si les deux commissions les deux
rapporteurs ont pourtant fait un travail
approfondi il est redoutable parce que
vous demandez à votre position
finalement dans dossier des mesures un
peu rugueuse dont l'application va être
complexe et dont les résultats au moment
où je vous parle sont incertains mais
surtout c'est un exercice redoutable
tout simplement parce que je crois que
le gouvernement ne nous facilite pas
toujours la tâche
j'ai parlé il ya quelques secondes de ce
vent un peu de colère en tout cas d'un
raidissement mais d'où vient-il je pense
qu'il vient d'une perte de confirmer
cette perte de confiance et je ne
mésestime pas au moment où je vous parle
madame l'extrême difficulté de la tâche
mais cette perte de confiance vient trop
souvent des volte face des tâtonnements
comme l'a dit tout à l'heure philippe a
qui ont émaillé cette gestion de la
crise depuis les masques étaient
inutiles
le gel des tests qui manquait au départ
les frontières qui ne fallait surtout
pas fermé par idéologie sous prétexte
que le virus n'avait pas de passeport ou
encore par le pour le pass sanitaires
que nous avons voté qu'ils étaient
réduits sur des hôtes jauger qui ne
devrait pas toucher les actes de la vie
quotidienne
ce raidissement il est venu aussi d'une
forme de communication de gestion de la
crise qui reste très chaotique et qui
alterne à quelques semaines traire on
l'a vu il ya quelques jours juste avant
l élection départementale et régionale
dans la communication du gouvernement
qui alterne des périodes d'euphorie
triomphante et des périodes un peu
stressante de catastrophisme
tout cela donne sans doute le sentiment
encore une fois je ne mésestime pas la
difficulté de la tâche mais tout cela
donne le sentiment à beaucoup de nos
concitoyens d'une forme d'improvisation
d'une forme d'un préparation et au
moment où je j'emploie ce terme
j'entends aussi les mots du premier
ministre il ya quelques jours pour
avertir les français que nous allions
sans doute vers des temps difficiles et
qu'il fallait se préparer que les faons
françaises doivent se préparer bien sûr
et chacun a sa responsabilité j'y
reviendrai en matière de vaccination
mais il faut aussi que le gouvernement
prenne ses responsabilités on va vous
dire que il ya plusieurs pistes je
parlerai dans quelques instants du pass
vaccinale certes la vaccination c'est le
coeur de la stratégie alors de deux
sujets premier sujet pourquoi parce
qu'on sait très bien que le souci c'est
les trop 4 millions de personnes
fragiles les plus très en disant à peu
près 20 % des plus de 80 ans ne sont
toujours pas vaccinées 10 % des plus de
soixante dix ans et trente et quelques
pour cent de ceux de celles qui sont
fragiles et qui ont des vulnérabilités
pourquoi ne pas lancer une opération
commando avec les médecins généralistes
il leur faut des 12
il faut un porte à porte téléphonie
c'est eux qui rétabliront une confiance
mahdaoui je vous vois hocher la tête
mais permettez moi de vous dire on ne
parle que ce qu'on connaît bien
au moment où je vous dis
j'ai eu tout à l'heure un professeur de
médecine générale et deux mers dans mon
département qui malheureusement parce
que nous sommes un des départements
champion de france de l'hôtellerie de
plein air des campings et qui avait
jusqu'à présent été à l'écart de la
pandémie et qui là est en train de subir
une forte hausse et bien à noirmoutier
en nous annonce pour la semaine du 2
août
des doses en moins ça va faire trois
cent cinquante rendez vous qu'il va
falloir des commandes et à saint gilles
et saint-hilaire dans le centre de
vaccination 500 qu'il va falloir
décommandé est à peu près la même un peu
moins pour les sables-d'olonne
ce n'est pas une critique je veux
simplement que vous m'indiquer que vous
me répondiez pourquoi il y a plus de
doses pourquoi il ya moins de doses dans
un département touristique où on va
devoir vacciner pour des gens qui
viennent d'ailleurs la deuxième
injection est toujours bien sûr pour
essayer de répondre à ceux qui sorte
d'attentisme à l'injection de la
première d'autres parce que on va vous
accompagner sur le pass madame néanmoins
mais bon sang il nous faut des 12
il faut des doses il faut un
approvisionnement
c'est évident une autre suggestion
une autre suggestion parce qu'on sait
très bien que le variant désormais
s'attaque aussi aux jeunes pourquoi
est-ce que vous ne créez pas une
obligation une obligation de mettre
d'installer dans chaque classe primaires
de collèges de lycées et d'universités
des capteurs de co2 parce que il est
désormais scientifiquement établi ce
sont pas les gouttelettes sont les
vecteurs de propagation de contamination
ce sont les aérosols et ses quelques
dizaines d'euros par capteurs sur deux
pour quad anticipons nous pas bien sûr
qu'il faut isoler et nous allons vous
accompagnez moi je dis depuis des bois
depuis le premier confinant j'étais
favorable à des mesures un peu plus dur
pour isoler je préférerais que l'on
puisse isoler certains qu'on isole tout
le monde en confinant tout le monde mais
là aussi le séquençage
pourquoi est ce que la france est trop
faiblement contributeur au séquençage
internationale parce que trop longtemps
on a fait la même erreur que pour les
tests on
amy le secteur privé à côté dans ma
propre région
c'étaient les seuls deux chu qui avaient
le droit de séquencer il ya quelques
jours encore je ne sais même pas ce
qu'il en est au moment où je vous parle
le privé n'étaient pas mises à
contribution sans séquençage parce qu'il
y aura d'autres mutations on avance dans
le brouillard et il n'est pas normal que
vis-à-vis du danemark ou d'autres petits
pays la france et de ce point de vue là
une contribution médiocre dans quelques
jours ou dans quelques semaines vous
aurez vous votre collègue monsieur vers
ans a signé un arrêté qui va établir le
nombre ou numerus clausus des élèves
notamment en réanimation l'an dernier
vous êtes passés de 72 à 74 ans dix ans
le manque de l'animateur a doublé si on
veut prévoir demain ne passait pas cette
année de 74 à 75 ou 16 franchissons un
pas c'est important pour préparer
l'avenir
voyez jeu il serait tellement difficile
nous à l'opposition de s'opposer
systématiquement de ne rien dire de ne
rien proposer
j'essaie aussi de proposer j'essaie de
comprendre ce que l'on me remontent du
terrain parce que nous sommes tous ici à
droite ou à gauche des élus terrain bon
alors évidemment maintenant veut dans un
texte est au fond du texte d'abord notre
état d'esprit est ensuite nos positions
que nous allons défendre
aux côtés de nos deux rapporteurs l'état
d'esprit je me suis fait comprendre
depuis le début cette crise il a
toujours été sur cette ligne de crête
difficile je le dis encore pour les
raisons que j'ai cités d'un équilibre
entre la responsabilité et entre
l'exigeant cette responsabilité c'est de
faire en sorte qu' on ne sombre pas dans
la démagogie mais qu' on puisse vous
donner les moyens d'agir et de gouverner
pour protéger les français
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que dès le
2 décembre dernier les présidents de
groupe qui était au déjeuner qu'avait
organisée à l'elysée le président macro
monte entendu j'avais indiqué au
président de république que j'étais à
l'époque favorables à l'obligation
vaccinale pour les personnels soignants
et les personnels en contact et nous
allons vous accompagner de même que je
le disais
sur les mesures d'isolement avec les
précautions que nous rapportons revend
vous proposez nous ont déjà ici cité qui
ont été votées en commission
l'exigence c'est celle qu'on doit aussi
à tous les français pas seulement à ceux
qui comprennent la nécessité de la
vaccination mais aussi aux français
qu'ils peuvent avoir dès la 10 ans et
nous devons relayer leurs interrogations
parce que parfois même si nous ne la
comprenons pas toujours elles peuvent
être légitimes en tout cas on doit le
répondre autrement que par des injures
ou par des invectives
c'est tellement évident et de ce point
de vue là nous avions évidemment dans
cet état d'esprit respectant cet
équilibre nous avions voté le pass and i
ter première formule mais c'est aussi au
nom de cet équilibre que nous allons
vous demander de nous accompagner pour
accepter les modifications les
amendements qui ont été votés dans nos
commissions et qui pourrait être par ici
ou là proposé alors évidemment la
pandémie revient quel choix avant nous
le premier choix bien entendu c'est ce
qu'ont déjà été réalisés les
confinements les mesures généralisée il
découvre ce cessez le pire de toutes les
solutions
c'est le pire de toutes les solutions
vous savez bien chers collègues
tout simplement parce que ce sont des
mesures qui touchent tout le monde
quitte son trait attentatoire à nos
libertés à anould liberté aux libertés
de tous
elles sont attentatoires aussi à la
santé psychique des français et
notamment des plus jeunes mais on a les
chiffres on a les chiffres des suicides
on a les chiffres du mal être qui ont
exprimé notamment nos plus jeunes
compatriotes
et ça on doit l'avoir en tête idem pour
une économie qui redémarre
c'est pas seulement des aspects
matériels économie c'est aussi quand ça
marche pas bien des souffrances et des
souffrances sociales
donc non bien entendu la pire des
solutions c'est le confinement et je
pense que le pass est sans doute la
moins mauvaise je sais que certains
d'entre nous d'entre vous propose la
faction la vaccination obligatoire pour
le moment je n'y crois pas d'abord je
pense que nous n'avons pas les doses mes
chers collègues nous n'avons pas les
doses pour la vaccination obligatoire je
pense aussi que lorsque vous posez une
obligation vous ne pouvez pas en posant
l'obligation ignorer les sanctions et
l'application que vous en faites sinon
vous affaiblissez
alors vous affaiblissez l'autorité et
enfin je pense que nous sommes dans un
pays si fracturé que cette obligation
aujourd'hui nous ferait prendre de
grands risques donc je pense que encore
une fois le pass vaccinale doit être un
chemin peu étroit difficile mais sur
lequel nous allons vous vous accompagner
à quelques conditions vous l'avez
entendu condition que de faire en sorte
que ce pas ce soit lui aussi d'ailleurs
équilibré c'est à dire qu'il soit juste
qu'ils soient proportionnées je l'avais
dit il ya quelques jours dans une
formule un peu lapidaire oui au pass
sanitaire mais non impasse arbitraire et
c'est ça qui est important pourquoi
parce que au fond du fond pourquoi
est-ce que nous allons vous accompagner
sur ce cette décision difficile parce
que nous croyons qu'une société ne peut
tenir debout que si il y à là encore un
autre équilibre entre les devoirs et les
droits nos droits sont le reflet de
notre devoir
les français chaque français bien sûr
chaque citoyen un devoir
vous avez aussi en tant que gouverneur
un devoir et ce devoir c'est aussi de ne
pas blesser les droits nos droits le
droit aussi des citoyens mais je pense
que les garanties que nous vous
demandons elles sont importants j'ai
entendu quelqu'un tout à l'heure qui
citait la revue de la devise
républicaine
cette question de la liberté avec mon
collègue hervé marseille nous avons été
il ya une dizaine de jours les premiers
à vouloir saisir le conseil
constitionnel non pas pour mettre un
nouvel obstacle sur le chemin de ce
texte mais tout simplement pour dire aux
français que nous allions prendre toutes
les précautions toutes les garanties
pour leur liberté
de même que quand philippe bas propose
de rétablir cet état d'urgence
j'ai entendu le ministre la question
n'est pas que on aime se voir ou pas
qu'ils aiment venir au sénat ou pas la
question et que dans des institutions
dans une vie démocratique
on a besoin de procédure et la procédure
démocratique qui permet de cadrer
l'action du gouvernement c'est le vote
d'un texte et c'est pour ça que il nous
propose une date butoir au 31 octobre
j'espère interpréter correctement ça sa
pensée voilà est fondamentalement cette
garantie de liberté elle est importante
de même que d'ailleurs entre nous il
faudra parce que je pense qu'il va y
avoir un problème pour des restaurateurs
des bistrotiers qui vont faire des
pertes de chiffres d'affaires
voir avec votre collègue de l'économie
pour avoir des systèmes bien entendu
dead pour ces chefs d'entreprise qui à
nouveau seront victimes et j'en profite
pour dire que le fameux régime pénal de
sanctions et heureusement on veut passer
de ce régime pénal un régime
administratif s'est pas seulement une
question pour moi d'efficacité c'est une
question de principe
parce que ces restaurateurs ils ont été
des victimes alors ne les transformons
pas avec l'épée de damoclès pénale ne
faisons pas de leur statut de victimes
des statuts de délinquants aux coupables
pour moi c'est aussi ce signal
extrêmement important l'égalité ce qu'a
fait jean talent de seine pour essayer
de tenir compte notamment pour les
salariés
entre le 15 septembre pour avoir de la
souplesse dans le calendrier ça c'est
important
la première question d'égalité c'est
l'approvisionnement en dose il faut
avoir des douze pour mettre les uns les
autres sur un plan d'égalité enfin je
terminerai par la fraternité qui est
toujours le mot de notre devise
républicaine qui est oubliée parce que
chacun demande pour soi même de la
liberté est toujours plus bien sûr et
pour soi même aussi toujours plus
égalité et si possible un peu plus que
l'autre mais la fraternité la démocratie
la démocratie et c'est heureux que
beaucoup de français une majorité nous
dit-on pour le moment accepte et veulent
le pass sanitaires la démocratie ce
n'est pas seulement la règle de la
majorité c'est d'abord bien sûr la règle
de la majorité mais c'est aussi le
respect des minorités et nos gouvernants
doivent s'astreindre à porter une parole
publique tine blesse personne qui ne
stigmatise pas j'ai écouté olivier
ferrand il a stigmatisé personne mais
quand un porte parole oppose de france
une france et d'anti france deux clans
le camp du bien le camp du mal une
france forget a même dit at-il dit
qu'ils seraient capricieuse et déficit
contre une france d'israël laborieuse et
qui serait volontariste ça n'est pas
acceptable
j'ai souvenir d'ailleurs d'un autre
porte parole qui avait aussi stigmatisé
une france elle qui roulait au diesel et
fumé des clubs et quelques semaines
après on avait le mouvement des gilet
jaune prenons garde à une parole
publique est toujours tranchantes
lorsqu'elle est très stigmatisant la
fraternité madame et et je vous attends
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'amendement il ya
eu la question de la deuxième
délibération dîtes nous ce soir que tout
français
qui aura un proche en train de mourir
qui vivra le crépuscule de séjour à
l'hôpital
à l'ehpad dites-nous confort confirme et
nous que ce proche
quel que soit son statut vaccinal ou pas
pcr en situation d'urgence
il pourra assister la personne qui lui
est cher pour accomplir le grand passage
c'est une question de fraternité et je
conclurai et madame je conclurai aussi
sur cette fraternité
cette épidémie elle nous rappelle à
notre devoir de fraternité mes chers
collègues quoique nous croyons que nous
soyons ce devoir de fraternité qui sans
doute aujourd'hui dans cet océan
d'individualisme est un peu oublié et
voir un peu perdu nous avons partie liés
les uns avec les autres c'est ce que
nous dit finalement cette pandémie
c'est à dire que quand nous vaccinons
plusieurs d'entre nous l'ont dit nous
prenons soin de nous mêmes mais nous
prenons soin aussi des autres et c'est
fondamental c'est ce quinze jours victor
hugo a écrit dans quelques mots si beau
et c'est ma conclusion
ma vie est la vôtre votre vie est la
mienne et notre destinée est une merci
de votre attention
la parole est à madame marie pierre de
la gontrie pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour six
minutes chers collègues
pendant soit
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame et monsieur le président de
commission
madame et monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues chacun ici ce soir a
rappelé la gravité de la crise sanitaire
que nous vivons les chiffres ont été
égrénés nous les avons à l'esprit mais
depuis 18 mois nous nous retrouvons ici
régulièrement votre gouvernement madame
dans la gestion de cette crise a commis
une triple faute
la première c'est l'infantilisation en
considérant que les français devaient
être menées comme des enfants ce furent
les attestations pour avoir le droit de
sortir
c'est désormais au fil du temps à chaque
fois des leçons qui sont assénées comme
si chacun ne pouvait pas entendre la
gravité de la situation
ça a été ensuite l'autoritarisme qui
évidemment comme une caricature démontré
lorsque le président de la république
s'exprime et que l'on apprend aussi
ensuite par la presse que même ses
propres ministres
ces équipes ne savait pas précisément ce
qu'il à être annoncé et que l'intendance
à les suivre
de fait les mesures annoncées et est
évolutive puisqu'elle ne pouvait pas
trouver leurs applications mais aussi
les errements et les revirements et
c'est peut-être ce qui est le plus
gênant car aujourd'hui la confiance dans
votre parole a singulièrement fondu
puisque à cette même tribune
il nous a été tenu des propos définitifs
sur le pass sanitaire qui ne se seraient
jamais appliquée pour des actes de la
vie quotidienne mais y compris au fil
des étapes sans vouloir rappeler des
souvenirs cruels sur l'inutilité de
porter des masques et au fil du temps à
chaque fois la parole publique a été
dévalorisée tout cela a mené à
un triple désastre un désastre sanitaire
un désastre démocratique est un désastre
social le désastre sanitaire nous
constatons les contaminations qui
repartent les soignants épuisé
l'insuffisance de vaccins on ne dit pas
suffisamment ça a été rappelé encore à
l'instant et peut être demain si nous
l'avons bien entendu l'arrêt de la
gratuité des tests le désastre
démocratique avec ce débat qui nous
amène non pas à travailler dans de
mauvaises conditions a mal travaillé à
mal faire la loi
parce que nous n'avons pas de recul pour
réfléchir de manière sensée à ce que
nous voulons proposer et acceptée
puisque chacun ici est dans un état
d'esprit constructif comme à chaque
étape de la dizaine de projets de loi
que nous avons débattu ici
de ce fait nous avons un texte qui est
confus et je reprends car je sens que
les parlementaires ne sont pas forcément
considérés comme des références les
propos de d'une autorité
constitutionnelle
la défenseure des droits qui souligne
notamment l'hymne intelligibilité des
règles car si demain un français est
capable d'expliquer ce qu'il est
possible de faire ou pas je pense que
nous pouvons le saluer vous allez aussi
découper l'espace public entre les
endroits où nous pourrons aller les
endroits nous ne pourrons pas aller et
donc opposer les populations vous allez
instaurer un contrôle d'une moitié de la
population par l'autre puisque vous
voulez qu effectivement dans chaque lieu
il faille montrer son pass pour entrer
pour ne pas entrer je passe sur les
difficultés nous y reviendrons lors de
l'examen des amendements
certains qui ne peuvent pas les obtenir
parce que les dates ne sont pas les
bonnes
parce que les vaccins ne sont pas les
bons parce que les pays où ils les ont
administré ne sont pas répertoriés vous
allez donc amené cette population et a
mené un contrôle
vous allez porter atteinte à la liberté
d'aller et venir et au final vous
souhaitez de fait c'est quasiment
assumer une forme de surveillance venir
lisez une forme de france en liberté
conditionnelle
un désastre social parce que les enfants
la jeunesse va être de fait dans une
grande difficulté pour accéder à l'école
aux loisirs
vous allez mettre en place une
assignation à résidence avec un
isolement
vous allez du coup un site est à l'arrêt
du dépistage car les gens ne voudront
pas être isolé vous proposer des mesures
que nous allons sans doute refusé ici de
licenciement une forme de discrimination
à l'emploi entre les vaccinés et les non
vaccinés et vous allez évidemment mettre
en grande difficulté les catégories
sociales les plus défavorisées
celle là même dont nous savons qu'elles
sont les moins vacciner alors la seule
réponse nous disons au groupe socialiste
c'est la vaccination universelle
j'ai entendu avec plaisir un certain
nombre d'entre vous après que ça a été
développé par notre collègue monique
lubin la défendre tout en indiquant que
ce serait l'étape suivante
mais pourquoi attendre l'étape suivante
puisque nous savons qu'il faut du temps
pour la mettre en place
nous proposons nous proposons un certain
nombre de mesures pour qu'elle soit
effective dès demain sanctionnables dans
quelques semaines et de manière à ce que
entre temps un certain nombre de mesures
de contrôle évitent évidemment que les
situations périlleuses soit en place
vous vous y refusé son but il sans doute
pour avoir le plaisir de revenir dans
quelques mois devant le parlement
sauf que nous aurons encore une fois
pris du retard
nous aurons encore une fois manqué
l'occasion de permettre à nos
concitoyens de nous sortir de cette
crise merci
la parole est à madame brigitte
bourguignon ministre délégué auprès du
ministre des solidarités de la santé
chargée de l'autonomie pour répondre aux
orateurs
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
rapporteur madame le rapporteur et
madame la présidente de la commission
j'espère n'avoir oublié personne je
voulais tout simplement je serai très
rapide parce que nous allons passer du
temps ensemble demain je voulais vous
dire que bien sûr je déplore comme vous
l'urgence dans laquelle nous sommes
tenus d'élaborer ce texte et je peux
vous dire que j'ai infiniment de respect
pour le débat parlementaire pour vous
dire combien je déplore moi aussi que
nous sommes obligés de travailler dans
cet urgence pour autant vous l'avez dit
vous l'avez tous rappelé la crise
sanitaire nous impose quelques fois des
revirements effectivement c'est le la
science parfois qui nous invite aussi à
le faire et à changer des décisions pour
lesquelles on avait une toute autre
affirmation il y a trois ou quatre mois
je crois que vous ont peut être
indulgent chacun et avoir l'humilité de
se dire que cette crise est bien nous
l'assumons il faut quelquefois revenir
sur des décisions qui ont été prises
préalablement je suis désolé alors moi
je vais très rapide parce que nous
aurons le temps demain d'entrer dans le
vif du débat est dans le vrai travail
parlementaire que nous allons mener
ensemble et je vous remercie pour la
mesure à une exception près de vos
propos pour vous dire que je reviens de
deux jours de déplacement dans deux
départements totalement différent
pourtant ruraux est ce que j'ai vu ce
que j'ai vu c'est un vrai affluent vers
les centres de vaccination ce que j'ai
vu c'est des personnes qui ont envie de
se faire vacciner plus jeunes beaucoup
plus jeune que ce que nous avions comme
public jusque maintenant ce que j'ai vu
c'est des enfants qui commencent à venir
se faire vacciner ce que j'ai entendu
c'est des soignants qui arrivent aussi
pour se faire vacciner dans les centres
de vaccination ce que j'ai vu séné 3 de
collaboration entre des collectivités
territoriales la rs les sous-préfets et
ça fonctionne très bien
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
ça fonctionne très bien ce que j'ai vu
ce sont des bus qui vont dans les
quartiers qui vont dans les quartiers
vacciner ce que j'ai vu
ses débuts ce qu'ils vont dans les
petits villages là les verts commencent
à fonctionner et ce que j'ai vu mesdames
et messieurs ce sont des soignants qui
adhèrent ce sont des personnes qui sont
venues est-ce que je peux terminer moi
je vous ai écoutés paisiblement
merci alors je sais que ce que je vous
dis ce que je vous dis vous retire
certaines de vos certitudes moi je vous
le dis ce que j'ai vu ce sont des
personnes très engagé et je pense qu'on
doit tous les accompagner parce qu'il y
ait encore des personnes à rassurer
c'est vrai et on ne doit pas les opposer
les unes aux autres je suis d'accord
avec vous il faut apaiser ce débat en
france ce que j'ai entendu aussi c'est
que nous avons des réfractaires qui sont
beaucoup plus entendu que les autres moi
j'ai vu tous ces silencieux qui pendant
ce temps là on s'est responsabilité
vaccinale et qui ont envie que notre
pays s'en sorte
je pense qu'on va y arriver je pense
qu'il faut qu'on puisse débattre
paisiblement nous aussi parce que nous
avons aussi un discours à tenir pour
rassurer les français et pour faire en
sorte que nous sortions définitivement
un jour ou l'autre de cette crise
sanitaire
merci et à demain merci la discussion
générale est close alors mes chers
collègues je vais lever la séance
prochaines séances samedi 24 juillet à
9h30 pour la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi relatif à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
la séance est levée
[Musique]